哈嘍大家好我是小俊。
站在今天這個SpaceX。
IPO的歷史性時刻我們決定加更一級節目。
我要請了SpaceX前火箭首席製造工程師洪立德。
一起來聊聊隨著SpaceX收購證和XAI。
並完成截至目前史上的最大的一期IPO。
那在太空與AI加速融合的背景之下呢？
這會不會是人類文明擴張的前奏。
你今天開始從這裡開車到洛杉磯。
也就是你剛好開進你的家門口的時候。
你最後一滴油剛剛好用完了。
這個就是火箭
就SpaceX第一個找然後來擴張整個SpaceX。
生產並且開發流程的其實是一批Mini Cooper的團隊。
銀行第一句話來問。
你有沒有看過可樂罐的生產。
他直接來一句都很淡定的。
說好那我接受你的辭呈。
我們的競爭對手是我們自己。
但是我們密切關注中國航天的發展。
大家好我是Louis。
我是Airis Fun的共同創始人。
那也是GP
我們是一個早期備在LA的美國的VC。
我們專門投美國的英科技項目。
不管是在太空、能源。
還是現在所謂的Physical AI。
那我早期一開始我是在SpaceX。
那我早期在FaceX。
我在早12年的時候加入SpaceX。
在SpaceX待了7年。
那時候到19年的時候離開。
離開的時候管7個部門。
3千多個火箭部位。
那我離開SpaceX以後。
去加入一家電池公司。
那在19年20年我們非常好運。
就抓到EV這個封口。
那那個時候呢？
也順利的在那個20年的時候退出了。
並且我在這家公司。
認識我現在的Partner。
那他來自於Tesla。
那是Tesla那個時候。
不管是Freemont。
然後還有這個
創立上海超級工廠的高管。
還有480電型
那我們兩個一起在。
上一家公司認識
那並且呢？
共同看到了美國
接下來這個20年的這個。
黃金的這個硬科技的這個機會。
那決定能一起離開公司。
在22年的時候開始做天使投資。
那去年成立了我們第一次基金。
對那做Air's Fund。
那開始來這個
基本上來支持
所有的這些硬件創業者。
我們今天邀請Louis。
是希望你能給我們聊一聊。
整個航天業
因為你對這個
非常了解在SpaceX非常多年。
然後後來也一直投資這個產業。
那我自己有一種感覺。
就是我覺得
現在可能對於航天業。
處在一個非常
奇妙的轉折點上
你看今年年初
SpaceX收購了XAI。
大家也覺得
SpaceX今年會上市。
今年可能是SpaceX的IPO年。
你是怎麼看待這個時間點的。
我覺得今年
從兩個維度去看這個時間點。
如果從市場的角度。
可以的確今年感覺像是一個。
你知道嗎
就是太空的一個chatGBT moment。
之前大家可能都
可能對這個行業
可能好奇
但是你說真的convictions嗎。
沒有這個convictions。
對 但今年
OK 從伊朗
說它要這個SpaceXIPO開始。
OK 我們就接到。
這個源源不斷的inbound call。
有人說
你對XAI
你有沒有SpaceX的股票。
你們現在在投什麼。
太空項目等等
這一些之類的
所以我覺得
從一個資本的角度沒有錯。
今年是的確是一個。
很大的一個轉折點。
可是你如果從
整個太空的這個發展。
OK 我不認為說。
今年是有一個特別大的。
一個inflection point。
但是它只是一個持續。
OK的 在這個領域的一個發展。
我們從
我說我從12年的時候。
加了SpaceX。
那那個時候
13年的時候
第一次跟伊朗開會。
那第一次開會的時候。
伊朗基本上就說
OK 我們呢？
目標
OK 是我們要去。
這個開拓這個宇宙。
反正SpaceXemission。
它是每一年
它都會在重複
重複重複的
對 那第一步
我們要做錢的
OK 那就是我們要能夠。
把這個回收火箭
這件事情
能夠先完成
我們的第一步
OK
也就是我們要有一個。
非常穩定
並且非常能夠量化。
並且經濟的方式
能夠運送東西
上下太空這樣子
對 那
OK 我心想
哇 OK 這個可以。
OK 這個
那我們可能
沒比10年
我可以做到這個事情。
OK 可能我們那個時候。
可能就稱霸整個市場。
對 那13年
我們開始在
就是做到這個項目。
15年的時候
第一次的這個reuseable rocket。
OK 就真的就誕生了。
OK 就第一次的這個。
12月21號2015。
非常寄圖這個日子。
對每一個SpaceX人。
給非常重要的一個日子。
我們第一次成功的。
把一支火箭
成功的送進軌道
並且成功的
把這支火箭回收
至今這支火箭
現在在LA
對 所以有到LA的這個。
朋友們其實
現在SpaceX。
可以到SpaceX的總部。
可以去看這一支
就是非常具有俱練性的。
這個火箭
對 那在那個時候。
其實我覺得說有一個。
你說的這個
就是轉折點的話
其實那是一個
很大很大的一個轉折點。
這個象徵的是
整個一個就是
全新的一個
就是之前大家認為。
一個不太可能的
一個太空時代
OK 現在真正的這樣開始了。
這個算是GBT-3 moment。
算嗎
我覺得是
其實在業界裡面
可以算是
甚至更大
OK 我不敢說
這是一個AGI moment。
但是呢？
它的確對我們
想想看
就是說我們今天有。
任何的運輸
你今天
如果我從A到B點。
OK 我運輸一次以後。
我就把這個東西
不管是火車
還是這個飛機
直接就丟了
那你想想看
這個東西能夠做起來嗎。
就是不可能量化
或者不可能
做任何事情的
可是當你
OK 能夠把這個東西。
做回收的時候
OK 那
這個東西才是
所有的起點
所以2021年2015。
OK 我認為對SpaceX。
我覺得對整個
太空行業來講
OK 是一個
OK 就是真正的。
一個轉折點
那
它在
我覺得左從右上面吧？
就是接下來
把這個整個reuse。
這個row開始的。
就啟動
但是呢？
我覺得對整個行業而言。
OK 是一個
就是
以前大家都公認
是一個不可能
而且是一個
蠻荒謬的一個事情。
OK 很多
所謂的在太空的這些。
這些
專家
就覺得說
SpaceX做這件事情。
根本就是不合理的。
OK 我們已經
試想過這個事情
這個東西也不符合。
經濟邏輯
更不可能符合
所有太空
OK 所需要的這些。
最尖端
最高級的這些
這些符合的規則
OK 但是SpaceX。
OK 家出窗公司。
在這個時候做到了。
所以我覺得這個時候。
是一個
轉折點是這個
對
SpaceX還有另外一個特色。
也就是說
我2012年的時候。
加入
對 2013年的時候。
OK 反正一樣說的。
這個東西
跟它接下來
這個rowman。
你在SpaceX走。
你會發現
除了這個以外
其實SpaceX。
在2012年的時候。
2013年的時候。
還在聊什麼事情
就是當我們
第一支火箭
已經發
才剛剛發射成功
一年勉強整個公司。
可以發射一次的時候。
公司已經成立
的火星小組
公司已經在決定說。
OK 我們現在
這支火箭
是沒有辦法到火星的。
是沒有辦法
OK 就是符合
就是人類所需求的。
就是真正在宇宙中。
在探索
OK 所以
我們需要一支更強大。
OK 並且更符合。
OK 這個沒有神的火箭。
所以那個時候
在2012年這個時候。
現代的所謂的新建。
就在那個時候
就已經誕生了
所以它在做這一代的東西。
但是它已經開始
想下一代的事情了。
是的
其實在SpaceX。
其實是非常非常
普遍的事情
我覺得大家看一下。
SpaceX不管是新建。
不管是新煉
不管是說現在是
太空數據中心
還是上月球什麼等等的。
OK 大家覺得說。
哇 是不是馬斯克。
哪一天晚上
OK 可能無聊
還是不知道在幹嘛？
OK 可能又在那邊亂。
在X上面亂發表這個言論。
但是這些東西
其實我們老在十幾年前。
在SpaceX的時候。
都講過
這些可能的path。
所以現在你說
你回歸到說
今年對我而言
OK 它是不是一個轉折點。
OK 它的確是一個轉折點。
因為我覺得
它在類似chatGPD moment。
它把太空這個事情。
更帶入所有的大眾。
更更帶入所有人的對話當中。
特別是資本
OK 從這個SpaceX開始。
IPO大家開始對這個賽道。
等等就充滿了
無限的這個想像
對 所以我覺得
從這個角度它的確。
但是從一個開發的角度。
這些事情
我們早就是在以前。
十幾年前就已經開始歸化好。
一直在執行
我很好奇
在一二年的
SpaceX內部的roadmap上。
二六年寫了什麼
這是一個很好的問題。
那秘密
對 當然也沒有
我必須說
它沒有寫這麼具體。
就是說二零二五年。
二零六年應該發生什麼事情。
OK 它不是這個意經。
OK 這個東西
但是呢？
它是有清楚的align。
就是SpaceX。
就是大家都知道
特斯拉有一個master plan。
對不對 就是大計劃。
OK 我第一不要幹嘛？
第二不要幹嘛？
現在第三
現在已經大計劃第三。
甚至有一個第四又跑出來了。
那SpaceX那個時候。
其實又有大計劃
OK 那SpaceX一直。
把自己定位成一個太空公司。
OK 所以
它的目標一直就是很簡單。
我們的公司的存在。
是為了要能夠開脫與證。
給全人類去探索
支公司就是終止
所以所有的事情
都是按照這個目標下去定。
它從來沒有把自己。
定位成一個火箭公司。
讓很多人這樣看
我相信在一二年的時候。
一定沒有料到大於模型的爆發。
沒錯
那你怎麼看在今年初。
更早一些時候
SpaceX收購了XAI。
這會是人類文明擴張的前奏嗎。
這是一個很好的問題。
我覺得最近呢？
這是不管是
SpaceX的人。
或者SpaceX外的人。
都在討論這件事情。
那其實呢？
你說這個東西
是不是在這個
SpaceX master plan裡面。
OK 這個呢？
不在這個master plan裡面。
我覺得這個master plan。
不是疫情
它沒有那麼辦法
能夠這麼厲害
預測到說
會有一個AI的爆發等等的。
但是它的確是說
我們需要在這個低軌這個地方。
做成一個全新的一個通訊網路。
那有這個通訊網路。
OK 那間接的
這是一個新的
一個數據的一個
一個數據的高速公路。
OK 那我給你
聽這個東西
可能會覺得有個抽象。
那我給你一個具體的一個舉例。
為什麼那個時候
SpaceX做要做新鍊。
OK SpaceX做新鍊。
有兩個中指
第一 OK
SpaceX要去火星。
OK
SpaceX的目標。
需要就是
它永遠沒有把自己。
覺得說
要把這個人類
變成一個多星球物種。
這是一個SpaceX。
跟伊朗常常在講的一個。
Vision
對 一個Vision。
對不對
那你跟任何投資人。
跟政府說你要去火星。
我覺得沒有一個人會買單。
OK 到今天為止。
OK 甚至像
Maybe Trump。
你知道這麼想要做什麼。
大家都不一定會買單。
說你要去火星幹什麼。
所以從SpaceX。
從一開始就知道
要去火星這條路
我們只有辦法自己去走出來。
那我們走出來
我們除了要能夠解決。
像這一種
科技的這種困難
OK 那當然
我們還需要很大筆的一筆資金。
那我們要一筆大筆的資金。
在地球上跟在太空上。
最近
OK 能夠做這件事情的。
OK 那就是通訊網路。
通訊網路
SpaceX也不是為了。
做通訊網路這件事情。
而做通訊網路
OK 這個東西
從第一原理思維
我們可以說
SpaceX的事情都是。
從第一原理思維出發的。
為什麼要在太空
做這件事情
即使你可以做了
即使你解決了
這個太空這個身家。
OK 上下喔
你把成本降低了
OK 你現在可以發射。
更多的東西
更便宜
所以你可以做這件事情。
但就算你可以做這件事情。
為什麼要做這件事情。
那從一個物理學的角度來講。
在太空訊息的傳輸。
在一個太空真空的環境裡面。
訊息的傳輸
從A點到B點
一起在地球上
任何最先進的光纖。
OK 管你用什麼5G 6G。
什麼G
OK 它都還要再更快一倍。
這就是自然的一個空間。
太空的空間的環境。
所造成的一個天然的優勢。
所以在這個優勢之上。
從第一原理思維
如果我今天告訴你。
你今天能夠有一個網路。
的傳輸速度
是比在地球上
增加一倍
那一倍在沒有任何加持之下。
那你會選擇
在地球上的網路
還是在天上的網路。
我覺得這是一個很直接的問題。
那SpaceX
直接已經在很久以前。
就看到這個東西
很久是多久
這個東西的計畫
新鍊的計畫
是在2015年啟動。
也就是2015年開始。
OK 當SpaceX。
OK 你說真的回收火箭。
完成了 降落了
OK 那公司開始慢慢的。
都在跨在第一步的時候。
他就已經立刻就想到好。
那我有這個平台以後。
我需要做我第二步的這個計畫。
那就是這個新機網路。
所以FCA並進了SpaceX。
它的目的是去增強新鍊。
這個是兩碼式
OK 我屬為了新鍊的。
在天空的訊息的傳輸。
OK 有這個樣天然的優勢。
那我們學會到AI。
OK AI的建設需要什麼。
那特別我們也在講。
AI的建設在美國需要什麼。
OK 我覺得這是一個。
很specific的一個問題。
OK 也就是X AI。
跟所有的巨頭
不管是Open AI。
還是其他這些能比。
需要算力
需要算力 Exactly。
對 那怎麼樣才會算力呢？
OK 我們需要
能夠做更多的數據中心。
好 那需要做更多的數據中心。
那就見呗 對不對。
那這個東西
我覺得講得很簡單。
對 那就見呗
就是錢的問題
就砸吧 對不對
就到處都蓋
OK 我趕快
因為大家的晶片
這邊多拿一點
OK 那如果這個世界。
這麼簡單的話
我覺得這不是一個問題。
但在美國的
我覺得在美國
做所應見的事情的人都知道。
在美國
你要做這種基建
OK 是一個巨難無比的事情。
OK 兩點事情
第一 你光
要拿到這個地方
你要能夠審批
你要能夠把這個電。
簽過來
你要把這個Permit。
OK 你要跟所有。
這附近的人都確定說。
他們OK
OK 我們這邊
這個的數據中心
不會對你造成任何危害等等。
這件事情就是要花費。
非常多的時間
OK 非常多的精力。
OK 第一 就是。
你這個數據中心的這個地點。
第一 第二
我們現在來講一個罪。
很明顯的一個事
就是說在很多媒體。
他已經講的
就是美國缺電
對
美國其實在AI之前。
OK 其實在上一代。
也就是我們在做
電動化的時代的時候。
其實就已經發現
OK 不管你有沒有AI。
美國你看整個美國的電網。
美國的電網
現在consist of。
差不多東岸跟西岸的電網。
OK 美國這麼大的國家。
其實電網就只有兩個。
東岸跟西岸
還有德州
OK 這三個三大電網。
然後大部分的電網。
已經是一個
30年以上的一個設施。
美國最新的兩個
核能發電廠
OK 是在1990年代的時候蓋的。
OK 所以從你在AI來之前。
OK 美國根據
就所有東西電動化的這個需求。
OK 已經有一個明顯。
在25% 差不多40%。
就是電網這個缺購。
那你現在再加上AI。
那就是根本就是
你知道就是一個
南上加南的一個問題。
那並且美國又是一個。
民主的國家
OK 你做什麼事情。
你不可能 OK
首先我去搶
就是居民的電來做AI。
對 你一定要能夠做。
data center。
你一定要能夠拿到。
一些額外的電
那剛剛已經就說了。
已經有這個額外這個缺口。
那再加上這個
你知道有沒有辦法。
這樣快速的這種
available的電。
所以電力的缺失
跟你說
沒有辦法快速
就是這種permit的這個需求。
OK 導致於在這個太空。
OK 其實對美國來講。
是有一個先天的優勢。
當你在把這個衛星中心。
發上去
並且像Spatia上說的。
分布式的
把它分布在全球的這個地方。
OK 其實呢？
OK 在太空裡面你的擴建。
只有一個東西是在取。
在控制你的速度的。
就是你自己能夠發多少。
在太空裡面
其實你不需要去拿permit。
OK 你也不需要去拿什麼。
這邊太多是怎麼許可。
你只要誰先上
OK 誰先拿到這個位置。
那這是第一個
那第二個
大家已經從這個
這個第一原理
在太空裡面的能源的轉換。
太空有無盡的這個太陽能。
那在太空的太陽能轉換。
大家已經從實驗證明。
差不多比地球上的太陽能。
OK 還有超多
超過十幾%
OK 這樣子的一個轉換率。
所以太空無盡的能源。
無盡的地方
OK 並且
OK 沒有限制你去開發。
所以為什麼這個XAI。
OK 跟SpaceX結合。
希望在太空數據中心。
其實是背後
這樣的一個底層邏輯。
有沒有可能是Tasla去收購。
SpaceX去收購XAI。
我覺得之前
很多人在講這個東西。
對 因為Tasla畢竟。
彪瓦自己是一個AI公司。
那就有這麼多的
Alternative Strike。
Physical AI 等等。
對
對 等等
看一下他們應該跟Match。
哇 那你怎麼知道。
最終這三個人
會不會在一起呢？
這個東西其實
也有一個懸念
OK 感覺有什麼事。
還會發生是嗎
或許
但是我不知道
這東西我不知道
我猜一次
但是呢？
我給你一個點
這是一個故事
我們在2014年的時候。
有一天
我們在這跟同事
在那邊互相
在那邊反正吃飯
中國吃飯
然後在交流的時候。
有一個同事在說
你知道嗎
我今天聽到了什麼消息。
我說老闆呢？
今天呢？
買了 X.com。
OK 這個網域
2014年的時候。
OK 所以
X.com
X
對 那反正
SpaceX
XAI
Tasla 沒有一個 X。
但是呢？
或許呢？
我在想
可能有一天
所有馬斯克的東西。
會像Alphabet一樣。
有一個空公司
然後所有可能都集成在一起。
因為你繼續看
我現在所做的每家公司。
其實呢？
是沒有什麼特別大。
就是沒有什麼
你知道嗎
說他們沒有關聯
我覺得
嗯
真的沒有關聯嗎
OK
現在 X跟SpaceX。
合在一起了
好
那Tasla在做的事情。
我覺得大家都很知道。
OK
不管是機器人
不管自動駕駛
所以本身實體的AI。
是Tasla在做的事情。
那你說還有什麼公司呢？
Neuralink。
Neuralink呢？
做腦筋接口
OK
大家常常說
OK 我們跟AI。
新的這個招呼是什麼。
是新的一個iPhone嗎。
OK
是新的一隻眼睛
新的一個耳機
OK
但是呢？
或許最直接的方式。
或許是一個腦筋接口。
這樣的一個直接的一個連接。
OK
一個人
想想看
你今天
你在跟我採訪
你今天隨時隨地
OK
有一個
電腦的這個負
這有點在後期
就是電腦的這個的負贖。
在跟你在提醒
現在我在講的此刻。
接著消息
你隨時在download。
在update
這個消息
我覺得這是一個
人跟AI之間
可能在英勞的眼中。
可能最終的一個
這個招呼
也是人需要
必須要在這個
新的這個時代裡面。
跟AI這樣一隻
共存的一個東西
那你說
那挖洞公司
不能coming幹嘛？
OK
一個挖洞公司
哇
在外太空的環境裡面。
在這麼高輻射的地方。
OK
你覺得人
真的可以像這樣
看完小說裡面
哇
住在這種的一個
這種所謂的這個
這個
就是這個
玻璃的這種的
這個圈裡面
他們一定要能夠住在。
Maybe在山裡面。
或者在地下
才不會被輻射的問題。
所以或許
所有的以往的公司。
都有為了一個
最大的大計畫
不能這些
所以你覺得
那個他14年
註冊的ax.com。
這個ax
代表的是什麼呀？
他最後
會變成一個
怎麼樣的一個
巨型網絡
他構築一個
什麼樣的系統
我猜測了
這次完全只能猜測。
根據你跟他
7年的工作經歷
真的
我覺得說
我覺得英勞
做什麼事情
其實
有他的想法
你可能當下
你沒有辦法
去理解英勞
我覺得這是很理解。
很正常的事情
就算我們身邊
跟他很久的人
其實很多時候
在當下
還是跟他有很多的這些。
你知道
分歧
還是有很多的這些。
你知道
慢慢就在討論
然後這些辯論
OK
但是呢？
很多時候
在後面
我們證實
OK 我知道
英勞是對的
OK
所以我們一個開玩笑。
做SFACE ID。
應該有一件這個t-shirt。
這叫做I told you so。
我早就告訴你
然後寫英勞
OK
OK 這個的 對。
那所以呢？
就是我們跟英勞
合作很久以後的
這個一個觀測
所以呢？
那我現在
出於三次
我覺得英勞
可能
大家都說英勞
應該有一個最終的。
Master master plan。
OK 就是他自己。
心裡在想什麼
但他從來沒跟人家說。
也沒跟我們說
但他註冊了一個X。
然後還註這些事情。
我不認為
自己家公司
是偶不然的
這是一些註思馬跡。
這些是註思馬跡
然後最終
這些東西
或許會
你和在一起
然後成為一個X
你說到註思馬跡
我發現FCI
從D1開始成立
他的願景是理解宇宙。
Our mission is to understand the nature。
of the universe。
所以他有沒有可能一開始。
就覺得跟SFACE X。
有某種關聯
而且他的logo。
是一個黑洞的寓意。
這是一個
我覺得你讀得比我還深。
OK 我還沒有想這麼多。
但是我覺得
我看很簡單
從一個AI的
這個競賽的這個角度來看。
你看看
你現在說的AI的巨頭。
不管是OpenAI。
不管是Claw
不管是Gemini。
還是Groc
你如果在想
各家現在在這邊競爭。
這麼久
幾年以後
我覺得現在
大家在開始講
就是某一個點
我要在這裡
裡面從一個巨頭
很明顯
Gemini
有Google的search。
OK 所以他想要在。
可能在這個搜尋
然後在這些反正文字的。
這個部分
他想要支撐吧？
對不對
Claw很明顯的。
從一開始就想要成為一個。
是一個
一開始想要賺錢
OK to be。
我想要給产生一個工具。
是一個
在coding的人。
可以使用的一個工具。
OK 所以他一開始。
就想要走一個to be的方式。
OpenAI是一個。
我是這個
反正這個行業是我發起的。
我想要發起一個最大。
大家都可以去通用的一個東西。
然後我的面對
也是大眾的這個
Consumer。
OK 跟大眾的
Groc是什麼
OK 大家就是Groc。
Groc有無限的。
x這個data
可是Groc是什麼。
就是Groc如果真的要走一個。
OK 一個真的
他的力足點的話
是什麼
他有的資源是什麼。
OK 他在馬斯克的生態。
那馬斯克的生態
我覺得有什麼東西。
比其他的東西
還有更多的data。
那我覺得他Groc。
或許會在
Physical AI。
也就是實體AI
也就是所謂這個
現在的實體模型裡面。
就世界模型
OK 我覺得
可能在這個裡面的力足。
對 所以呢？
你說這個xAI
他想要Understand the Universe。
我覺得這是一個點。
對不對 當然他是Universe。
我們所有東西都在Universe裡面。
但我覺得他更想說的。
他就想要跟你瞭解。
實體的這個世界
但是很不幸的是
至今xAI還沒有成為。
歸骨T0的frontier lab。
所以你覺得
xAI算是掉對了合併。
還是彎道超車
我覺得你這個問題。
就問到了我的這個。
不是我的expertise。
OK
我覺得很多人比我。
更厲害
但是呢？
我做一個猜測
不要竟然從第一原理。
我認為今年呢？
我在2026年的prediction。
我認為
今年的Groc
OK 大家應該可以拭目以待。
因為我覺得有很多之前。
OK 在去年Groc。
所做的這些投資
跟所有的這些
這些投入
我覺得在今年
會冒出來
所以我覺得今年是一個。
在AI的這個大戰裡面。
我覺得這個滿有意思的一年。
那我覺得這個AI。
你覺得去年
給Groc這麼快速。
建了10萬張
這個GPU的superdata center。
這個東西跑到哪裡去了。
我們看看
這個年26年
我們看看有沒有什麼東西跑出來。
我在想
SpaceX會兼容XAI的組織嗎。
你看剛合併
其實很多XAI的人都在離職。
這兩個組織是具有兼容性的嗎。
當然你對SpaceX組織。
可能更了解
對 我對SpaceX組織非常了解。
因為對X
我們也有認識一些X的朋友。
那這些反正
就怎麼形化家常吧？
這邊聊的時候
我感覺兩個的體系。
的文化是滿類似的。
都是馬斯克文化嗎。
都是馬斯克的文化。
那馬斯克文化是什麼。
馬斯克的文化
基本上我覺得有一個字。
一個一條sentence可以形容。
是什麼
move fast break things。
你就是快速的直行。
快速的疊帶
這個東西
我在SpaceX裡面。
我們是深刻的體驗。
但是在Graph裡面。
我認為也同樣的文化存在。
你覺得Starship缺一個大腦嗎。
Starship缺一個大腦。
這是一個好問題
我覺得什麼東西都缺一個大腦。
還是做不出來
但是你說Starship。
具不具體缺一個XI這個大腦。
這個東西我就不評論了。
我覺得這個東西
可能
但是我覺得說
這不是一個
還沒有到那個地方。
OK
我覺得還滿早起的。
因為這讓我想到了。
流浪地球裡面的MOS。
在流浪地球裡面
對 它指揮了整個空間站。
所以看到這個新聞。
會讓我想到這個電影。
我認為這是一個
很容易可以想像的一個聯想。
對你印象和你在外太空。
對所有的任務
不管是去探索
還是去擴張等等
你覺得你能夠發多少人。
那我覺得你的
其實最好的
最可靠的一個伴侶。
就是AI跟機器人。
如果SpaceX在今年上市的話。
它意味著什麼
今年SpaceX真的上市了。
我認為
我認為主流市場
OK 對太空這個賽道。
OK 可以變現
然後是一件事情
我認為他們是真正的買單。
因為這個東西
我們從一開始
我們在做投資的時候。
一直在講這個事情。
OK 但是
我覺得我們太多投資。
20年
20年的SpaceX。
其實也不是一家小公司。
OK 每一年發
基本上在這個
太空領域裡面
也是一個非常明顯壟斷的。
一個公司
比別人都是
也在開下新一件
所以在各方面的壟斷。
其實在這個前提之下。
在20年的時候
還是很多人看
太空這個賽道
還是覺得說
這個賽道
真的是一件事嗎
OK 真的是一個。
就是一個產業嗎
他們當時怎麼看SpaceX。
當時怎麼看SpaceX。
我覺得很多時候
大家在這個賽道裡面。
要不是
你跟我今天聊天
或者在這個賽道裡面人。
你平時
在地球上生活上
旁邊這麼多Open and XAI。
大家還有這麼多有意思的東西。
大家不會去關注
說我往天一看
這個天上還能夠有什麼東西。
就算
我跟你說
SpaceX做了什麼。
等等的
這些東西已經進在眼前。
並且數據的話
大家就覺得
這個是真的是滿了不起的事情。
但是這個可能
Maybe 20年以後。
Maybe 20 30年以後。
或許我們做到那又怎麼樣。
太空有什麼機會
但是我覺得這一次。
就準備SpaceX的IPO。
並且Starlink。
在過去這幾年
實際在資本裡面的數據。
這個漲幅
我覺得給大家
這個對太空的信心。
那我覺得這只是第一點。
我覺得這個在
數據只是第一點
那我覺得太空
還有很多其他的
這些東西持續還在待發。
其實這是我們整個基金。
跟我們在投資方向的。
一個最底層的邏輯。
在我們繼續探索
這個商業航天的話題之前。
我也想花時間來聊聊你自己。
就很多人都知道
你在SpaceX跟馬斯克共識了7年。
那在這之前和之後的人生。
是怎麼展開的
大學我是在 Stanford 裡面。
Mechanic。
就是機械工程本科。
那你是上大學來的美國。
沒錯
OK 從臺灣是嗎。
我是出生在臺灣
然後我很少跟爸媽。
就出國就基本上留學。
那因為我爸媽一直是XPAT。
那麼兩個都講德文。
所以一直在德國公司裡面工作。
對 所以我很少的時候。
就離開臺灣
然後在德國住了一下。
然後後來又去了香港。
又去了廣州
中國我住了8年
我在廣州敦灣高中。
然後從廣州那邊直接申請。
然後來美國讀大學。
我那時候是
印象很深刻
我那時候是99年。
那時候申請
來 Stanford。
那個時候 Stanford大學。
那個時候國際生
還是一個非常非常小的一個族群。
所以我印象很深刻。
那個時候整個中國。
OK Stanford那一年就入學兩個人。
一個是我
然後另外一個是一個北京的一個German。
OK 那整個就國際的族群。
OK差不多也不到200人。
那香港可能有
差不多有快10個人。
所以臺灣有幾個
對 所以那就是99年的時候。
反正報考了Sanford。
很好運地進了Sanford。
後來Sanford。
那我在Sanford。
讀完了機械工程的本科。
那畢業的完了以後。
第一份工作
我其實有兩個選擇。
我可以第一
選擇去當Google。
早期員工
或者我可以選擇
去做一個Fortune 500。
OK的這個
這個公司
一個自動化生產的一個工程師。
這個選擇
你選擇哪個
我那個時候
那我選擇了呢？
去了這個
去做了這個工程的這個概念。
OK 那其實兩方面。
我覺得在現在這個時候。
很難想像
其實2003年這個Sanford。
其實在那個時候
不管是創投
還是不管是這個
出創公司
還是這些新創
它是一個
還是一個非常
還是一個
非常小
但也不是一個主流的一個行業。
怎麼說呢？
因為你看他們的這個。
每一年都會有一個。
這個叫 career fair。
就是說你演藝學生的公司。
可以來這邊
來照併Sanford的學生。
那時候 career fair。
有一個主 career fair。
OK 也就是
所有這些大公司
Boyne Microsoft。
GN 福特等等
他們來主要的那個。
career fair。
然後你說像什麼
Google
還有什麼這些什麼。
出創公司
等你現在今天叫出來。
所以這些老大們
都在旁邊的一個
叫做出創的一個 career fair。
OK 所以那個時候。
即使在2003年的Sanford。
這個時候還是一個這樣的文化。
那個時候我們的畢業生。
大家分享
想要進大廠
想要進顧位
想要進Fortune 500的公司。
OK 所以那個時候。
我也沒有那麼
那麼的先進
對不對 我也覺得說。
跟著主流
對 我也覺得跟著主流走。
反正我去大公司
去訓練一下
OK 那我也去學習學習。
所以我就加入了Absent。
那那個時候
在西北
美國的Portland。
西北的總部
那這個地方
其實也是美國生產的。
最起點
OK 現在這大家。
你還聽他很多
特朗普在那邊講
美國生產
那我們在2000年初的時候。
其實就經歷過這個 thesis。
那個時候
我在Portland那邊。
被招進去
然後做什麼
做Absent裡面的這個墨水甲。
你不是
以前
大家還印這個東西出來。
所以有墨水甲這個需求。
那在這個西北的總部。
也是一個
美國的這個墨水甲。
生產的總部
那Absent在全球。
總共有五個總部
在生產墨水甲
墨水甲也是整個Absent。
最賺錢的事業權
OK 就是靠墨水甲。
在支撐整個Absent。
這麼大部分
什麼LCD
這麼其他自動化
等等這樣的開發
那我在美國的總部。
那我是
那個時候
在美國的總部
這個墨水甲工廠
一條生產線
就兩個工人
一個工人
在前面這邊放貨
然後另外一個工人。
在這個線的底端
這邊在檢查這個成品。
然後再檢查這個品管。
然後全程
全部是完全全自動生產的。
那我就是被招進去。
在做這個生產線
這個設計跟開發
那通常這個生產線。
在中國那個時候
2000年初需要55個工人。
都可以做這樣
工人工人這樣的組裝。
那美國就是在這樣的。
兩個人跟55個人之間。
OK 這樣在跟全球這樣在競爭。
那就是我第一次體驗。
到在美國生產
那並且就是所有的這些什麼。
日本的這些豐田的生產系統。
什麼等等的
那個時候
其實我在 Stanford 畢業以後。
有點在學了
在一個 Master。
在所有的這些工廠管理。
然後我也成為
在整個
Appson 集團全球最年輕的高管。
那個時候
我一個在
20幾歲出頭的人。
給管了整個
整個場嘛？
差不多就
70幾個人
對 那在全球的這些。
Appson
非常保守日本的總部裡面。
是沒有辦法想像這件事情的。
他說為什麼你會相信。
這個一個20幾歲出頭的人。
那我老闆那時候很挺我。
就說你就看看這個。
就給我的這個職位。
那是我工作的第一年。
就是我第一份工作。
在 Stanford。
我第一年你就當高管了。
第一份工作的
第二年我當上高管。
第一年我被招進去。
做一個工程師
設計這個生產線
然後很快的
我在第二年的時候。
開始Promod到高管。
為什麼可以這麼快。
而且是在一家日本公司。
是在一家日本公司。
我的日本
我的老闆也是日本人。
日本美國人
OK
這個好問題
我從來沒有問他
OK 這個我自動說。
我也自己也覺得
蠻莫名其妙
但是我覺得 OK。
那個時候
我覺得
所有在做的事情
我覺得我沒有一樣。
我不能做的
OK 並且我能夠做得更好。
我覺得年輕的時候。
人的一個特性
我就覺得說
不怕天高等等的
那也實際
OK 在這份工作的時候。
我在 Stanford的這個教育。
並且在後面等等
幫助我在這個早期。
在這個很競爭的這個環境裡面。
OK 就是反正快速的。
這樣突然而出
但是我在那邊工作的時候。
其實你回歸到
就是我現在
回歸到所有的這個。
所有的經歷
我發現在這一段的經歷。
是我所有經歷裡面。
OK 最累的經歷。
因為在工廠嗎
在工廠裡面最累的經歷。
怎麼說呢？
OK 我現在成為高官。
然後我現在反正
那他們有反正固定的。
這個工作時間等等的。
那我發現
我開始在往後的時候。
我在一天裡面
差不多前三個小時。
我就已經完成了
做一天所需要做
完成的工作
可是在這個日本公司。
OK 你又不能夠。
完成了
那我就回家
OK 我就開始
就是做其他事情
所以在接下來的幾個小時。
我就被逼
OK 在這個公司裡面。
就是基本上就待著。
OK 所以在第一份工作。
是最可能
上手的一份工作
OK 也是最簡單的一份工作。
可是對我來講
在整個經歷現在回頭。
還是一個最累的一個經歷。
那我在那邊做了幾年。
這個馬斯克
聽到覺得你工作不飽和的。
真的 真的
所以我們等一下
會講到這一點
OK 這個 對
那我在那邊做兩年。
我就覺得這真的是。
我沒有辦法再這樣待下去。
雖然生活是真的真的不錯。
但是真的沒辦法再這樣待下去。
那時候我就覺得
OK 好 那我要一個新的挑戰。
那我現在有很多的朋友。
那也是我那個
在金融圈
特別是在投行圈
然後就說
我覺得你的個性
OK 跟你這個認知。
跟你這個background。
給特別適合投行
我覺得你應該加入我們這個投行。
但是你要加入投行之前。
你需要一個MBA。
OK 因為這個是一個。
必須這個進入投行的一個。
敲門轉
敲門轉 必須要這個的。
然後覺得好
那我覺得這是不錯。
我也想要去借個新的挑戰。
那那個時候在
2006、2007年。
全球最厲害的這個。
反正投資銀行跟金融都在倫敦。
所以那時候我也沒有多想。
我就覺得說好
我要去最厲害的這個地方。
然後跟大家一起這個一起共識。
所以我就那個時候。
我就報考一個英國的MBA program。
所以我那個時候很好運的。
反正也進了牛津
那讀了一年MBA。
那準備進入投行
那個時候也拿到了工作。
那我畢業的那一天。
2008年
OK
那一天
LEAMON BROTHER倒閉。
OK 就是基本上我畢業的那一天。
OK 在這個Financial Times。
非常大的這個字體。
我還印象非常深刻。
那那個時候也就開始整個金融海嘯。
那所以在整個的這個歐美。
OK 基本上是
完全沒有任何的這個工作環境。
OK 就我既有這個工作。
也被撤毀了
那找了其實好幾個月的工作。
OK 人生也第一次遇到說。
哇 還真的找工作。
還真的蠻難的
要不回工廠
真的
但工廠也沒有機會。
然後什麼都沒有機會。
真的 歐美
我都早變了
真的是一個蠻難的一個點。
那後來想說
OK 好 其實歐美不好。
但是其實亞洲還不錯。
那就是有人就覺得。
那個就是提醒
那你對不對
反正你也會講中文。
對不對 你也來自亞洲。
為什麼不去亞洲 看一看。
對 那時候反正我很好運。
反正在香港
給找了一份這個
找到了一個
供應鏈的顧問公司。
這個加拿大的公司。
OK 所以我就開始。
OK 在亞洲這邊做顧問。
那做了顧問
碰到了我的錢的一個老闆。
那那個時候
大家就覺得說
討論得很好
然後一起也一起創業。
然後反正做了一些。
反正食品相關的這個事情。
那那個時候
你會覺得莫名其妙。
一個科技的人
然後一個工程
然後你做了食品的東西。
你是不是就
看起來就是一個
完全不搭的一個賽道。
但是其實我的家庭背景。
我是來自於一個食品家庭。
真的
對 我們家庭是
三代的這個食品夾工。
對 所以我不是
莫名其妙的就跑了。
這個賽道裡面
我在這個賽道裡面。
我們還有一些資源。
那那個時候
同時有一些新的想法。
新的模式
所以開始做了食品的。
反正這些所有的創業。
創業是哪一年了
我們在2010年初。
的時候開始創業
移動互聯網起來的時候。
在移動互聯網
大家都在做的時候。
我們在做食品
新食品
你不是做一個食品的平台。
你是真的做食了
是食品
食的
你好像一直都在做。
實業 對吧？
對 我一直在做實業。
因為我們本科是機械工程。
我老闆也是
反正供應鏈的一個大佬。
我們就說 OK
好的 機械工程供應鏈。
食品產業一直沒有被顛覆。
那我們來顛覆看看。
所以我們做了一個。
新的一個食品品牌。
然後迅速的反正也在。
這個亞洲這邊
反正開了幾個分店。
那也開始
反正有中央廚房等等。
反正做實業了
對
那在這個裡面
我的經驗是
我們在短短的兩年之內。
OK 開了七間店。
然後也有這個中央廚房等等。
反正一個
反正二十到一歲
OK 我覺得
那個時候
我們的收入等等
我覺得都不錯
OK 那
我覺得
很多時候你在看電影。
你會覺得說
好像我真的有一個那種。
你的生命裡面
真的有一個那個轉類點。
還是有一個這個 moment。
這個東西改變你
你接下來走向的
這個事情還真的就發生在我身上。
我覺得在這個一二年的時候。
我在 Stanford。
一個非常好的一個朋友。
那也是一個
SpaceX 非常早的員工。
他是 SpaceX 前一百員工。
也就是 SpaceX。
剛剛創立的時候
他就加入 Elon。
然後跟 Elon 一起。
反正把 SpaceX 從開始。
一直蓋到就是今天。
這樣子一個
一個非常好的一個朋友。
那他就突然間
反正就找到了我
就說
你呢 在現在在幹什麼。
你有沒有想過
要不要回來美國
而且呢 你有沒有想過。
要不要一起來做火箭。
對 那我覺得
我們在做那個時候的事情。
然後你在人在海外。
然後突然間接到了一個。
這樣的一個 call。
你會覺得就是非常莫名其妙。
這是很久沒有聯繫的朋友了。
什麼
什麼還沒久沒有聯繫的朋友。
突然間就冒出來
那為什麼想到你了。
那他就說呢？
我們現在呢？
是一個最快速增長。
OK的一個公司
他就說
他的原話是
We wear rocketship。
OK
我們是一個火箭
正在往上飛
那你應該
來加入我們
OK 一起
來在LA
這邊來做火箭
那我想聽這兩個點。
OK 第一 做火箭。
OK 這件事情
在美國已經聽起來。
OK 這聽起來有點。
蠻厲害的
在LA做火箭
我覺得你肯定沒有聽過說。
誰會想過
在LA這個地方
能夠做火箭
聽過在LA做電影。
是的
大家都是這樣
對
他就這樣說
他就說
你是我認識裡面
我覺得在工程
在這個流程裡面
最強的人
那我覺得呢？
你應該
OK 來接受一個新的挑戰。
來加入我們
對 所以在12年的這個時候。
反正我也沒有多想。
那個時候我想說
我做的視頻對不對。
我自己
我也想要找一些
可能新的機會
讓我覺得更大使命的機會。
所以那個時候我就飛過來。
對不對
我就真的來看一下Sveysax。
但是在那個之前
我其實沒有多想
就是不管是Sveysax。
還是太空這個賽道。
還是ELO等等
其實我老實說
在這之前
我都不知道
你不是那種ELO的老殘粉。
對吧？
完全不是
就算
我也不是一個少數的人。
你說12年
OK
你說世界真的有多少人認識ELO。
ELO那個時候12年。
OK 是一個
從PayPal
OK 成功
變現
變現完了以後
把全部變現的這個資金。
進去兩家
兩家
那個時候大家都覺得。
OK
不是太
太厲害的出雙公司。
一個是Sveysax。
一個是Tesla。
對
那時候就是
他跟我反正分享了這個機會。
對
那也分享了Sveysax。
要做的事情
那我覺得好巧不巧的。
是那個時候
我們剛剛不是有講到。
Epson這個故事嗎。
我Epson的那個老闆。
後來離開Epson以後。
去了日本
他是一個美國人
美國日本人
但是後來
他基本上就監管了。
日本整個亞馬遜
OK 在日本的這個。
就啟動
所以他那個時候
在12年的時候
說你不要去做任何事情。
我們現在
亞馬遜在日本
剛剛開始
OK 這是一個
你在這個人生裡面。
你不會再碰到第二次的機會。
趕快過來
OK 跟我一起來。
在日本這邊
把亞馬遜這邊做成。
所以我那個時候
在12年的時候
面臨兩個抉擇
一個呢？
是加入
大家都知道亞馬遜。
OK 在日本的
等性的這個機會
第二呢？
是加入一家太空公司。
然後來開拓宇宙
然後你選了第二個。
這個過程其實是一個。
我必須採買
是一個滿難抉擇的東西。
因為我覺得這兩個機會。
都非常的吸引我
對不對
你在面臨一個很難的機會的時候。
你一定會幹嘛？
你會OK
問問你身邊的人
那我所有身邊的人。
都跟我講一致的話。
這個問題你還要問嗎。
這問題你當然是加入亞馬遜。
誰會
去做太空幹什麼
太空有什麼機會
了不起 OK
這家公司很有想法。
英文很厲害
了不起了
可以全世界
一年發了十幾次
So what
OK 這衛星
也就是這樣
一年就發了幾個衛星上去。
沒
沒有什麼看頭
你一定要加入亞馬遜。
那我那時候也和姬姬好好聽。
對那我覺得說也滿難選擇的。
那後來為什麼決定選。
選擇加入SpaceX。
是因為我覺得說
SpaceX在做的這個理念。
主要開拓宇宙
OK 那把宇宙
開拓給全人類去探索。
我自己好好地想想這個東西。
我想說如果SpaceX真的做成了。
這將是一個前所未有。
我們從來沒有看過的世界。
不要說市場
沒有看過的世界
那如果我有這個機會。
能夠在早期的時候。
加入這個使命
但是我沒有去加入這個東西。
那我一定會後悔一輩子。
你是第多少號員工。
那個時候我加入SpaceX的時候。
已經一千多人了
對 所以我是一千多號員工。
我有兩個問題
你什麼時候意識到錯過了Google。
是一個特別大的機會。
是一個特別大的損失。
我其實從來沒有想過這個問題。
對不對
我覺得大家從今天。
OK 你看Google。
OK 是一個反正多大多大的公司。
對不對 那那個時候有這個機會。
但是其實你說那個時候。
錯過Google。
你後悔嗎
我覺得其實還好
我覺得人會後悔是。
你知道嗎
就是你知道
你應該做一件事情。
那你選擇
OK 你沒有去做這件事情。
因為你害怕
或者你選擇了更簡單的路。
然後你去做
然後你後面證明
OK 你是錯的
你的直覺是對的
但你沒有去follow你的直覺。
OK 那所以
那你錯過了
我覺得這人會後悔。
所以Google不是你的直覺。
我覺得Google。
那時候也不是我的直覺。
只是老實說
所以沒有什麼可後悔的。
我覺得還好
對 當然啦
當然OK
那時候加入Google的時候。
可能我現在對不對。
在夏威夷還有whatever。
但是
但是我覺得
我覺得那個時候的感覺。
在對SpaceX跟現在。
如果你說現在這個東西。
現在此時此刻
然後再回去說
你那個時候錯過了SpaceX。
那我肯定
對不對
我覺得這個東西
肯定會跟我一輩子。
你的那一段創業是怎麼結束的。
那個公司後來怎麼樣。
後來那家公司很簡單。
那家公司反正也是一個賺錢的公司。
也是一個小企業
它不是一個什麼Venture。
也不是一個什麼
你知道嗎
獨角售公司
它就是一個賺錢的一個公司。
對 那個時候
我跟我的老闆
反正就兩個人嘛？
也很好說
反正我就跟他說
很坦白地說
說我還想要做什麼事情。
他也很支持我
對 那反正我就把我的股份就給他。
那我就反正就退出了。
我就回到了美國
你跟馬斯克寫過
一封很有意思的信是嗎。
來解釋一個食品的。
一個做食品的人
為什麼要去做火箭。
這是非常好的問題。
對 這個呢？
這早期呢？
我覺得對觀眾朋友。
可能會覺得
這是一個莫名其妙。
為什麼要跟馬斯克寫信。
OK 那
講一下這個過程
就是說那那個時候。
在SFACEX
一直對這個
面試新的人
跟招聘新的人
有非常非常高的要求。
不可以就是
那
除了
除了就每一個人都要。
經過深刻的這種篩選。
可以這種多輪的
十幾輪的這種篩選以外。
其實一個最重要的點。
就是在這個篩選完。
每一個人都同意以後。
最後一輪
OK
都要馬斯克親自面試。
親自同意
OK
才有辦法加入這個公司。
回歸到2012年。
OK
我的確
那個時候
反正我選擇去加入SFACEX。
對
所以SFACEX。
把我飛回來的美國。
那也那一天
反正一天裡面
真的就經過十幾輪的這個面試。
跟所有公司裡面的。
這個工程高管
什麼所有人都聊了一遍。
那
後面
反正大家都覺得
同意了就是這人很好。
我們想要
想要招聘他
可是那個時候呢？
剛好馬斯克不在
因為馬斯克那個時候。
去澳洲出差了
OK
那那個時候
HR當然就很擔心。
OK
就很著急
他說
他也知道說我那個時候。
有一個亞馬遜的這個。
這個offer在等我。
那他就跟英朗說
這個人不能等
要不然你就破例吧？
OK
那你雖然沒有辦法。
親自跟他這樣的面試。
但是
只要寫一封
OK
這個介紹的東西
跟你這樣說吧？
OK
所以那個時候
我是一個比較
唯一少數破例
就沒有跟直接
馬斯克面試
然後就反正寫一篇。
自我的介紹
那跟馬斯克
那馬斯克呢？
基本上就問我說
為什麼你想要來SFACEX。
就是很簡單的
一個open-ended的問題。
對
那那個時候
反正我加入SFACEX的時候。
那我是加入
SFACEX的這個。
生產跟產品
然後跟產品的開發。
對那那個時候
大家一個很
像你一樣
一個問一個問題
你做食品的
食品跟火箭
跟你現在做這個事情。
有什麼關係
OK
那我就反正跟馬斯克。
稍微解釋了一下
就你在食品產業裡面。
其實食品呢？
被大的一個最
最普遍的一個誤解。
就其實食品呢？
從一個產品的角度。
是一個最難的一個產品。
OK
你需要在一個
非常短的時間內
OK
爆發的這樣生產
非常非常多的量
並且每一個東西的穩定性。
都會經過
全世界最高的
這種品質的審核
就是你的嘴巴這樣審核。
OK
所以它是一個
其實從一個產品的角度的設計。
跟這個規劃方面
OK
是一個非常非常困難的事情。
那我希望把這個
第一個我學習到了。
這些的精髓
OK
來把它應用在這個火箭。
整個的生產
跟這個等公益鏈上面。
就是這個點
它秒批
它呢？
這個東西讓我不知道。
我不在場
但是HR跟我說
是馬斯克
OK 看了以後
對
立刻就是反正
一分鐘內就拍板就好。
就行這個人
這是他跟我說的
但具體之中
發生什麼事情
反正我不在場
但是HR跟我說
我聽說
你比較喜歡通財是嗎。
這是一個很好的問題。
OK
就是你現在講到
就是SpaceX喜歡找什麼樣的人。
對
那SpaceX
你看早期的SpaceX。
一般認為說
你在做一間火箭公司。
航空航天公司
OK
那你又
你對不對
你不如波音的資源。
你不如波音的這個人。
對不對
那不如波音的經驗。
那你應該希望找
很多很多航空航天的這個專家。
你在早期的時候
來這個來追改
OK 但是呢？
這些點
OK 不會在
面試的時候
對你造成負面的這個影響。
可是呢？
他絕對不是一個
就是SpaceX。
就是專心在找的人。
就SpaceX看了這整個產業。
雖然說這個產業
在過去幾十年
其實沒有什麼大的變動。
那也都是這些人弄的。
OK
太空一直對大家來的認知。
來講
OK 都是一個
非常高規格
一個非常就是工藝化。
非常這種精工
非常一個兩個這種的客製。
這樣的一個生產
那馬斯克認為說
我們如果要真的打開宇宙。
給大家去探索
這是當然不符合的。
我們一定要有辦法。
能夠把太空
能夠跟大眾並且更。
這個
跟大量生產化
所以我們需要在這個業界裡面。
一個以外的人
可以進來裡面
給這些
這個業界裡面帶一些心血。
所以
所以其實SpaceX。
OK 招的
蠻多
其實從各行各業
那在各行各業裡面。
有各種不同精髓的人。
可以來加入SpaceX。
大家會直接覺得
宇宙離我好遠
這不是普通人能做的。
但是它其實比較反大家的。
普通認知吧？
我覺得這是一個
對
就是像我們剛回到。
可能最出錢的
就是所有
不管是投資
還是說這些從業者。
大家都覺得說
這個太空離我們
是一個很遠的東西。
那我問你一個問題。
你想要去太空嗎
如果有這個機會
想啊？
OK 你想要去
對不對 想要去太空站。
想要去越州看一看。
想要去越球看一看。
Perfect
OK
那
回到你剛剛問題
就是太空離我們遠嗎。
其實呢？
在你我的這個
就是
不要說這個生命裡面。
對
不要說我們老的時候。
其實在這個未來的。
十年到十五年之間。
OK 其實人上太空。
OK 不是一個遙遙無極。
就是你要一個特別太空人。
OK 或者你要是一個特別。
或者你要是Jet Basil。
OK 才有辦法做的事情。
門檻會是多少
嗯
如果SpaceX做到。
SpaceX該做的事情的話。
馬斯克的目標
OK 是一張
頭等艙的一張機票。
哦 一次能帶多少人。
嗯
給一個航空飛機
差不多這樣的規格。
就以新建造的規格。
上百
除了金錢以外的
其他門檻嗎
當然
你呢？
當然還不能夠有這些。
天然的疾病
OK 當然就不是這方面的。
就是專家
但是呢？
馬斯克跟SpaceX那時候初中。
OK 就是希望能夠做一個。
反正大家都可以體驗。
的一個項目
嗯
對 那這個東西
來自起源
在他們的這個
你知道Plur Origin。
都已經證實了
其實呢？
就是說年齡
或者你不同的行業。
進上太空上下
以這個身體這個需求的標準。
OK 其實沒有那麼的高。
那在SpaceX。
在過去幾年
如果你有關注的話。
對 它有幾個這個。
所謂的這個
民營的這個
太空這個任務
為什麼刻意找尋
你可以看出
為什麼是一個
一個老師
跟一個就是
普通的一個醫生
或者是一個
從來沒有太空經驗的人。
我覺得SpaceX。
也要證實這件事情。
就是任何人
OK
可以在這個
太空的這個平台上面。
可以上下太空自如。
那一些
以安全
非常穩定的方式
這樣想想
嗯
你剛才講
你跟馬斯克寫信
那你第一次見他是什麼樣的場景。
有被嚇到嗎
嗯
我不會說嚇到這個。
這個
這個詞
但是我就說
因為我12年加入SpaceX。
13年的時候
就跟馬斯克開會了。
對
12年還不能開
12年的時候還沒有開會。
那13年
我是12年年底的時候加入的。
所以差不多也要快過年了。
那13年年初的時候。
剛好跟馬斯克
OK
這邊
馬斯克年初的時候。
都會跟全公司
OK
發表了一個這個
年中大會
OK
就年初大會
我們今年
目標要做這邊
25件事情
然後大家看這個東西。
哇
我們如果能夠做
前面兩件事情
可能就很了不起了。
但是這SpaceX。
目標就一堆一堆
每一年都一堆一堆。
一般每年能實現多少。
這算OK啊？
這也不能算是一個。
就是一個
你的所謂的
一邊的這種的
就是KPI
OK
我覺得很多員工
很多公司把KPI。
就是試著非常非常。
盛景的
但是這個東西是
可能對馬斯克來講。
對
如果是他的話
然後全公司都像他一樣。
因為我們可以
所有完成都可以完成。
但我們覺得說
看這個整個List。
OK
如果能夠完成
就前三
就前五
我覺得公司
已經很厲害很厲害了。
一般每年能完成
百分之多少
差不多前三前五
但是百分之
我如果要一個具體的。
我覺得百分比比較。
比較難給一個百分比。
OK
因為這些東西
但是差不多就是
反正我們不只要
能夠成功
回收火箭
還有一年發射50次。
然後等等
等等
這樣加下來
這些東西
對
差不多一年
當然它是以
重要度這樣子
來排表的
所以能夠
完成的前幾個
我覺得都已經
公司已經算是一個。
在整個行業裡面
已經是非常不容易了。
第一次聽他演講
感覺怎麼樣
這任何有意思
你看今天的馬斯克。
今天的馬斯克
我今天也在
聊聊說
今天你看X
馬斯克天天在X上面。
亂說話
我就希望他
能夠少說一點話
如果你看他
2012年
2013年的時候。
那個樣子跟今天
完全是兩個人
OK
2012年
13年的馬斯克
基本上不是一個
可能是你認識
裡面所有科技
裡面CEO
最不CEO的一個CEO。
這麼說
OK
就是你可能都會覺得。
CEO那是
你知道嗎
就是一個
光鮮亮麗
然後能說能到
對不對
然後說的
每一句話
大家都知道
就是被他
就完完全全的
這個
說心
今天他被認為
是全世界
不是的人
今天是
對
就是有點諷刺
2012年不是
2012年13年。
不是說他不會講故事。
而是那個
那個風格
完全不一樣
2013年
他是一個極端內向的人。
極端內向到什麼程度呢？
也就是說
雖然我們在自家
我可以在自己公司內。
我可以在做這個
就年度的這個分享。
你可以感覺的
馬斯克是非常激怒的。
這個不舒適
不舒適到
你比他還
感覺在台下
感覺就比他在台上。
還不舒適
這很難用言語形容。
但是我覺得
每一個人在
你跟一個人的
兩個人的招呼之間。
對不對
你要覺得
他要非常的不舒服。
你肯定
也可以感受得到
對
間接的
就是我們所有人
在那個時候的感受。
對
馬斯克在2012年。
2013年的時候。
是一個非常
不像今天
OK
比較會講故事
比較會面對媒體
面對這個大眾
OK
比較會傳達
這個大來這個訊息。
OK
他是一個
反正非常
但是我覺得
在某一些方面
馬斯克還是馬斯克。
一直都沒有變
OK
他是一個非常直的一個人。
一個非常表裡如一的一個人。
因為你發現
他對
我們這樣的表達
是這樣
他對外界的表達
也是一樣
其實說
以前的這個訊息
跟後面的訊息
基本上是一致的
就是基本上
馬斯克身為一個領受。
一個非常的
非常大的一個優點。
對
那所以那時候
我們在
在看他那個反正演講的時候。
對不對
我覺得呢？
大家呢？
OK
就是撇開他講的東西。
可能我覺得一點
非常非常明顯的
OK是
大家都被他的這個真誠。
我覺得說打動
那我覺得呢？
為什麼大家
可以跟馬斯克這麼走。
那並且一直共識
OK
我覺得馬斯克
是一個非常真的人。
到今天
我覺得我還是認為。
他還是
還是那樣的馬斯克。
為什麼開始
進入獵鷹9號的
製造環節的
這個是
是一個臨選機制嗎。
就是公司當時的組織。
是什麼樣的
它有哪些垂淚的部門。
你進去做的是什麼。
我進去做的呢？
其實我是在這個
太空船
就是飛龍號這個部門的。
所以我第一
飛龍號
對
所以我第一份工作呢？
其實是一個工程師。
OK我是在飛龍號。
然後專門設計
跟開發
跟製造飛龍號
的內部
的所有
就是我在負責的
那那個時候的
SpaceX的組織。
非常非常的簡單
SpaceX那個時候。
你說有一千多人
對不對
我加入的時候
那你會覺得
一千多人
然後這個
這個組裝公司很大。
OK這也很多人了。
對那你如果
我給你對比一下
就是相比
OK在波音
在洛奇馬爾
你在ULA
這個組織裡面
相同的
一年跟SpaceX。
一樣在競爭
發射這個
這個火箭
這個公司
給他們
相同的
有一萬個人
在做這個事情
也就是SpaceX。
當初是一個人
比十個人
這樣的比例
OK在做一樣
真是超越的事情
這個時候
已經是他成立了
多少年了
這個時候是一二年。
就是剛好十年
對
十年發展了
一個一千人的組織。
沒錯
SpaceX是
2002年的時候。
創立的
但是
到十年的時候
大家還是不相信
他這個太空的故事。
我覺得遠遠
因為還太早了
對
我只不相信吧？
或許
我覺得可能
根本就不是
對大部分的人
可能不盡是
可是
SpaceX在做的事情。
OK對
NASA
就是一個很重要的事情。
對
所以那個時候
一二年
加入
對不對
那SpaceX就一千多人。
那你說
那個時候的組織
是什麼樣
SpaceX的組織。
是非常品的
也就是
每一個火箭團
在太空船
有一個大大小小的部門。
那每一個部門
基本上
會有一個
主要負責
某個的工程師
我那個時候
也是其中的一個人。
一個團隊
只有一個負責人
然後他同時
也是工程師
他要幹活的
工程師
要幹活
要去採購
要去生產
要去開發
等等
就是一個人
如果說
那這個人
真的就有一個洞
這麼重要
就是
他們是不可替代的。
就是公司那個時候。
也沒有太多的資源。
說你有太多的這種替代。
當然
當然也是有
有一些back up。
但是極端極端的
每一個人基本上
你都負責你的部位。
那如果你做不出來。
全公司就在等你
基本上
我對近來的人
這個需求
跟這個要求非常的高。
但是一旦進來了
我給予所有
每一個人
有非常非常大的
這個責任
比這非常非常大的期望。
他是人才密度高的組織。
是人才密度
我怎麼信用
Spaceate早期的這個員工。
一般來講
有幾個可能特性吧？
第一
都很年輕
多年輕
大部分20幾
了不起30
你那時候多大
我那時候
Good question。
我12年的時候
差不多
你就是30出吧？
差不多吧？
你看
帥
我都忘了
對
差不多30出頭
這個時候
已經算大了
但是
在周邊
他們20出
30的人
基本上
都是工程能力
動手能力
特別強力群
並且也有
無盡的時間
跟無盡的能力
在這個公司裡面
OK
反正
花無盡的時間
我可以去做
一件非常重要的事情。
傳統火箭
公司的人不多
對吧？
傳統火箭的公司
非常的多
就是他這個背景的人。
加入SpaceXS人多。
就傳統火箭
公司的背景的人
他可能是一個
senior的
或者有幾年
background的這種人。
加入SpaceXS人多。
基本上非常的少
OK
其實也是很簡單
不是說
他們不慎任
而是這個公司的文化。
跟傳統火箭公司的文化。
基本上是兩家公司。
OK
那SpaceXS有一句。
就是那個時候
我們也是一個
開玩笑的一個詞
也就是說
你在SpaceXS裡面。
如果你要不要待
可以超過6個月
那恭喜
你已經是元老了
就是SpaceXS即使花。
很多很多的精力
也可以照最好的人。
但是
在一開始加入
並且這種的轉換率。
還是非常高的
OK
就是很多人進來SpaceXS。
有人認為說
哇
這完全不是我想像的。
這個公司
或者我可以慎任的。
一個環境
所以他們很快的
就
我覺得好壞
都是這樣
對
就是在
很多人
你加入的時候
很快
你就會意識到
你是不是跟
整個大環境
OK
是同一個
這個
這個緯度吧？
OK
我跟這個
同一個這個
這個Waveline。
然後要不然的話
你就是很快就選擇。
就不適合我離開
嗯
當時除了飛龍號
還有哪些平新的部門。
哇
那個時候
飛龍號有
反正火箭
就飛鷹9號
反正你說
各種的引擎
飛鷹1號沒有嗎
飛鷹1號
對
就是飛鷹
飛鷹9號
飛鷹1號沒有
為什麼沒有
飛鷹1號呢？
其實呢？
這是一個
嗯
這是一個好的問題。
為什麼飛鷹1號沒有。
對
SpaceX
你想想看
身為一家出創公司。
這裡是一個
你從0到1
OK
SpaceX
大家都聽過
飛鷹1號的故事
飛鷹1號
差點導致
SpaceX的倒閉。
對
SpaceX
這家公司
我有足夠的錢
我們可以
做我們所有的利益。
然後可以發射
3次飛鷹1號
我們成功了
OK
這家公司就成功
如果失敗了
那我們就太笨了
我們就乾脆去
做其他事情吧？
OK
這就是公司這樣出職。
所以
公司一開始
冒進令
把飛鷹1號
在這個
非常的危險的當中。
終於做出來了
2008年
飛鷹1號
第四次發射
OK
成功
過了前3次
都失敗了
大家都覺得說
公司要倒閉的時候。
反正大家
反正
杯水一讚
OK
把所有的資源
都混在一起
勉強擠出
第四次飛鷹1號
然後在第四次
成功了
2008年
那個時候
你找不到工作
我找不到工作
SpaceX也快倒閉了。
就是那個時候
同一年的時間
SpaceX
反而成功了
每一家公司
你如果是一家火箭公司的話。
你成功了
你會做什麼
我會延續
你當然會延續
你會盡量找我成功了。
趕快做訂單
趕快來我們趕快賺錢了。
對啊？
OK
飛鷹1號成功以後。
立刻
SpaceX就把飛鷹1號。
就把它就退役了
這是為什麼
OK
因為SpaceX。
從來不把飛鷹1號。
當成是公司的中職。
因為SpaceX。
從來不把自己
定位成一家火箭公司。
它從來不把火箭這個事業。
OK
當成是一個公司的中職。
火箭是一個必須
要完成的東西
來達到它要追走的目的。
但是火箭只是一個過程。
它是手段
它不是目的
它是一個手段
對
所以飛鷹1號
OK
證實了
一個群人能夠開發。
OK
一隻火箭
然後我們能夠把它設定軌道。
成功
那同時飛鷹還沒有成功的時候。
銀廊就開發了飛鷹9號這個計畫。
那飛鷹9號
反正在跟飛鷹1號並行。
在開發的時候
在2011年
OK
也非常好運
也成功了
那飛鷹9號的成功。
讓SpaceX
拿到了NASA
第一張的訂單
OK
那也為了這個SpaceX。
後面
就所有這個計畫
開始做了一個起點。
一和九的區別是什麼。
為什麼一
它同樣作為手段
它被廢棄掉了
而九是一個更好的手段。
如果火箭不是目的。
我們從第一原理思維。
開始在推這個東西。
就是如果你是SpaceX。
你的目標是
我們要去地球以外的地方。
然後做一些非常有意義的事情。
那你肯定不能夠仰賴在。
一個飛鷹1號的這樣平台上面。
飛鷹1號是什麼呢？
是一間極小的一個火箭。
最好的這個組合是可以。
差不多在一噸的東西。
OK 上太空
也就是小型迷你的衛星。
那相對的
飛鷹9號
OK 是飛鷹1號的25倍。
它是什麼的25倍。
它的載體的重量
載體的重量的25倍。
OK 所以它可以。
真正的在
不管是重要的衛星。
還是OK
一些比較重要的機構。
在低軌開始建設一些。
比較重要比較有意義的一些事情。
OK 那
所以呢？
那再來就是飛鷹
那你會說 OK
那飛鷹9號那新鮮呢？
對不對
那你如果真的目標。
那為什麼新鮮沒有錯。
這個故事並沒有停在飛鷹9號。
飛鷹9號在2010年。
第一次成功
OK 那在2012年。
也就是SpaceX還在非常早期。
OK 也就是非常。
其實也沒有很早期。
已經10年了
是10年了 沒有錯。
但對它自己還很早。
對 還很早期
怎麼說早期呢？
那個時候呢？
SpaceX在一年。
能夠發射一次火箭。
就已經很難很難了。
OK 在2012年的時候。
一年
那個時候火箭發射。
是一個很大的事情。
OK 所有人都會。
聚集在火箭發射的地方。
然後反正
你也發現
老美有各式各樣的迷信。
OK 不管是穿綠色的衣服。
還是穿到特別的襪子。
還是坐在一個特別的位子。
等等的 OK
穿什麼樣的襪子
坐在什麼樣的位子。
反正每一個人
有每一個迷信
他們覺得說
我在哪裡成功的
我就要立即留著
我不要改變
OK 對
馬斯克有這樣的迷信嗎。
我不知道馬斯克有。
但是我們的同事
有這樣的迷信
不過anyway。
在那個當下
OK 就是
在2012年的時候。
SpaceX就說。
就宣布了基本上新建計劃。
OK 就是我們知道。
飛行9號沒有辦法。
讓我們打到
我們最終我們需要去的目的。
我們需要一支更大的火箭。
飛行9號唯一幫助我們的。
第一 賺錢
因為我們是第一需要錢。
第二
OK 它幫助我們。
OK 認知我們怎麼樣。
從一支燒火箭
做一支大火箭
讓我們能夠
做一支更大的火箭。
這其實是飛行9號。
其實最重要的一個。
一個這個思維這個邏輯。
這次載體擴大了多少倍。
這個載體擴大25倍。
那下一步呢？
到新建
到新建呢？
基本上在這個9號上面的5倍。
我們常常講
在業界你也沒有人講。
一個叫做
它送一公斤
OK 上太空的費用。
OK 這個東西是一個。
在太空產業裡面
一個很重要的一個KPI。
那也是一個
就是為什麼顯示說。
為什麼SpaceX。
OK 跟SpaceX來做的這個革命。
我給一個具體的例子。
給你看看
你可能就比較
比較理解
就是在SpaceX之前。
每發一公斤東西上太空。
差不多是一兩萬美金的事情。
一公斤
就一兩萬美金
SpaceX出現。
就是說這是一個
非常非常扯的事情。
OK 我們一定要。
透過飛行9號
透過回收
我們要把這個東西。
大大的降幅
那SpaceX的確重要的這個東西。
SpaceX
把這個成本
OK 直接透過了回收。
飛行9號
降到了3000元。
OK 也就是這樣快要。
反正就是十分之一。
快要十分之一
這樣的一個階段
那新建
希望能夠達到目標是什麼。
是希望100元以下。
到這個
所以你從
任何東西從兩萬元。
OK 降到100元以下。
是200分之一的時候。
其實有很多
在以前
在太空裡面談
的這些天方夜談
OK 我要在太空裡面。
改行令
我要幹什麼的
現在
在帳上
都是可以算得過來的。
一些項目
這也是剛剛回答到。
可能在這個
interview的最初的點。
就是真正的SpaceX。
OK 現在的
一個轉折點是什麼。
就是非常明顯
我們SpaceX。
大大的降幅了
把這個東西
運輸在上空的這個成本。
並且把這個載體
的容量跟重量
大大的量擴大了
列寅9號
等他的歷史使命完成以後。
他也會消失
嚴格上是
但是你看現在
現在的波音
是不是有747
還是有777
還是有787
這種大的飛機
是不是有一個737。
它還是有不同的型號。
有不同的型號
有不同的作用
那飛機9號
是一個非常的
在這個新來的
太空產業裡面
還是一個非常重要的。
一個角色
那基本上是現在
產業的一個737。
但是飛音1號肯定是。
他用不了 對吧？
長期來看
飛音1號其實也不是沒有用。
實驗性
飛音1號那個時候。
達到了什麼程度
能夠在差不多一噸。
OK 能夠到一個。
就是到一個軌道裡面。
那現在在這個市場上面。
非常火熱的一家公司。
也就是Rocket Lab。
的火箭
OK Electrons。
就是現在在發射的一年。
可能就發射75次了。
它的這個載體
還不到飛音1號的3分之1。
所以你可以換句話說。
飛音1號
在一開始的時候
其實就已經有一個。
非常明顯
它是可以變現的
只是SpaceX。
並沒有選擇
我是一家火箭公司。
我停留在這個階段上面。
我要繼續的
為我要Ultimate。
要做的事情
然後繼續邁進
所以走了
他們現在走的這個路。
但如果SpaceX。
這家火箭公司的話。
飛音1號
其實是有它的用途的。
那其實在那個時候。
比較敏感一點的
大家很多人說
那個時候
英鎊還接到了
這個美國政府的單。
就是你乾脆不要搞火箭了。
對 這個東西不賺錢。
但是你有這個技術。
那不如
來幫助這個國防
還是什麼其他這些賽道吧？
但那個時候
SpaceX就堅決。
這不是我們的終止。
跟我們沒有關係
所以我們不做這個事情。
所以選擇走這條路。
你當時是怎麼從
飛龍號掉去了飛音9號。
我那個時候在飛龍號。
加入的時候
反正開始做整個的熱掌管。
SpaceX的第一張單。
就是GENASA的單。
是負責把地面上的東西。
運到了國際太空站。
OK 那你要做這個事情。
你除了要有一隻火箭。
你還有一個太空的這個太空船。
把這個貨物
到火箭升到太空以後。
把它載到這個太空站。
這樣的任務
那飛龍號就是上面的這個。
這個最後的這個
就是所謂的Last Mile吧？
最後一公里
最後一公里 對
對 那就是這個定位。
那所以那個時候
我是負責所有
飛龍號的這個內部的嘛？
所以內部也是什麼。
象徵什麼意義
就是飛龍號
這邊有非常多的
這邊高深的科技
可是呢？
太空人唯一接觸到的部位。
就只有接觸到我的部位。
因為太空人一打開。
他只有看到內部的這些。
你知道他所謂的
客觀電影
都是在描述這個部位 對吧？
Exactly
這就是我負責
沒有錯 就是我負責這個部位。
你的上一份工作
還在做食品
然後突然開始負責。
這麼有科幻場景的。
一個地方
你是什麼感受呀？
感覺很新奇
有什麼跟我們
就是普通認知不一樣的嗎。
或者跟科幻電影力不一樣的。
你說這個太空船內部。
還是說這個工作
就是關於太空船
嗯
哇
太空船內部
大家一定會覺得
哇
這是一個非常高大上。
OK的一個這個
你知道太空船的內部。
哇
這是不是像
科幻電影裡面小說。
這樣子
什麼都是很高級的這個。
AI這種機器自動化的東西。
那其實呢？
簡單來講
這個呢？
就是一個全世界
最高科技的IKEA。
OK
最高科技的一家家具。
真的
OK
怎麼說呢？
你說
其實你在做什麼
你在做一個
全世界最高科技
OK的儲貴
怎麼樣最高科技呢？
第一
要是最輕的
然後第二
OK
在最輕之下
還要能夠承受到
所有家具都沒有辦法承受。
的這種的重力
並且幾倍以上的重力。
這就是我那個時候。
其實主要OK在做的。
這個一個工程的問題。
那還有第三
你身為在這所有的東西的中心。
你怎麼樣跟所有的系統。
這樣的這個共和
OK就是系統的
就是這兩點
你怎麼樣做一個
最強的一家
給你怎麼樣跟
所有的東西
就完美的這樣的共和。
就這樣協調
因為這些東西可能。
並不存在
還要定制是什麼
不只定制
OK
就完全是很多時候。
我們要自己開發的。
所以你們要做家具。
可以這樣想像
可以這樣講吧？
OK這個東西
這個家具呢？
對
這個東西
有一些家具
我可以說這個儲貴。
可能比一棟房子還要貴。
儲貴多少錢
這個具體素質
我們就不透露
但是你可以想像
可能比一棟美國的房子。
不是LA的房子
這是舊金山的
但是在可能比一棟美國的。
中西部的房子還要貴。
就這樣能夠承受高大壓力。
對
那這個東西沒有任何的。
這個產品
有具備這兩個
這種的共和
很少有這種產品
就是我們自己
要看到說開發的一個東西。
這裡面有多少SKU。
你說在裡面的
內部這個部分嗎
對
SKU的部分還好。
但是你講了一個
很重要的一個部分。
你覺得整個火箭
SKU其實是很多的。
對
這個部分
是多少
我們具體素質
我們不說
但是我給你一個概念。
也就是
我給你一個
數量級
一個數量級
猜一下
就SpaceX在做這件事情。
他說OK
我們要做一個火箭工廠。
然後我們要開始做。
第一個
這大量的生產
我請問你
好
你覺得他認為
什麼樣的團隊
最適合做這件事情。
對
什麼樣背景的團隊。
假設你今天是SpaceX。
OK
你要請
就是來做這件事情的人。
因為掌管這件事情的人。
你會找
你會認為說
全世界現在什麼
既有的公司
最符合做這件事情。
就他如果在這家公司待過。
你能給我幾個選項嗎。
好
我給你講
譬如說波音公司
肯定怕死了
好
那再來譬如說
食品公司
OK
譬如說像Tyson。
還是第三汽車公司。
譬如說像
Mini Cooper。
這幾個
汽車公司吧？
汽車公司
應該是第一選擇的。
也就是Mini Cooper。
就SpaceX
第一個找
然後來擴張整個SpaceX。
生產並且開發流程的。
其實是一批Mini Cooper的團隊。
你可能會覺得說
OK
Mini Cooper這個車子。
很多人覺得
這個車子很好看
OK 很Q
但是這東西跟SpaceX有什麼關係。
為什麼不是奔馳寶馬呢？
對
為什麼不是奔馳寶馬。
OK
那Mini Cooper。
有一個特色
也就是他在
這個車系
是在所有車系裡面。
剛剛回到你問題
最多SKU的車系。
你開一台Mini Cooper。
我不要你有沒有買過。
還有你朋友有沒有。
但是你也可以感覺到。
我的屋頂
可以是這7個顏色。
我旁邊的這個
這個後視鏡
可以是幾個顏色
內部怎麼
整個加起來
它的SKU是所有車系裡面。
OK
最高的
也就是SKU
Mini Cooper的生產。
現在所有車系裡面。
真正達到了一個高量。
但是高SKU
變化控管的一個生產系統。
那
那個時候
這個也是最符合
SpaceX
OK的生產系統
那SpaceX
你說為什麼
SpaceX會很高的SKU呢？
那個時候
SpaceX在發射的時候。
就是飛行9號
所以你就覺得
SpaceX到今天為止。
OK
就是飛行1號
飛行9號
現在可能興建吧？
給人就三個產品
可是呢？
在裡面的人
大家都知道
飛行9號
在早期的時候
沒有兩個飛行9號。
是一模一樣的
這是為什麼
所有SpaceX。
每一個飛行9號的發射。
都為了下一個飛行9號。
再收集數據
對的 錯的
好的 壞的
所有的東西都納在。
立刻納在
給下一支飛行9號裡面。
立刻
OK
改進
立刻
疊帶
然後立刻發射
飛行9號
在我們早期的時候。
企業裡面
可能發射上百次
沒有兩支飛行9號。
是一模一樣的
因為它需要疊帶
因為它不一定
不能保證
每次都能成功
每次都成功
但是
每一次
你都會學習到
不一樣的東西
對
所以這是為什麼
在火箭的這個生產線裡面。
有了一個這麼
一個高
高量
穩定
但是高變化
讓你一個虛仇
然後你後來就掉去了。
飛行9號做
首席製造的工程師。
對
我在飛行9號
反正做了一年
有一年
對
反正像我剛剛說的。
我的項目是
備受矚目的
很多太空人的
這些回饋
等等的
反正
那個時候
在SpaceX有另外一個笑話。
也就是說你在SpaceX。
如果
你做一件
你怎麼知道你做得好。
還是不好
OK
你做得好
唯一的獎賞
公司
就會給你更多的任務。
更多的事情
唯一
你再說
你做得好
你再多做一點
那時候
我在飛行9號裡面。
反正做了這第一個項目。
那他們後來
你也知道
SpaceX
反正接下來
13年開始
接下來的快速
準備要擴張
飛行9號這個項目。
對
飛行9號
在一開始
OK
在
12年的時候
全世界的發射
OK
美國
包括中國
包括俄羅斯
全部加起來了不起。
全世界發了77次。
那那個時候
2012年
2013年
開始規劃
整個飛行9號的製造。
跟這個的
這個亮度的時候
銀行就非常的明顯。
我不怪
我所有的東西
我們一定要按照
每一年至少發射
40次以上
將下去規劃
之前一年發多少
一年
OK
全球發射77次
SpaceX在2012年。
2013年等等
了不起
OK
就發射了一次
在一家發射一次的公司。
英朗給全公司的目標。
OK
就是說我們在這個火箭部門。
我們至少要有
一年40次以上
OK的規模
為什麼是40次
不是30次
不是50次
就是good questions。
OK
但是那個時候
英朗就很明顯的
就是不要說40次。
30次
OK
說10次
你在說一家公司
OK
了不起
我們今年做了
做了一飛一次
我跟你說
那10倍
這樣的產能
你怎麼感覺
那你瘋了
OK
那你不要說10倍。
那現在說40倍
至少
以這樣的
以至少
以這樣的起點
這樣的規劃
好
那時候大家也不知道。
英朗想要什麼
反正就是好
英朗
SpaceX非常明顯。
反正英朗說了算
給大家就相信英朗。
OK
所以現在
火箭部門
要大量這樣擴張
我們要怎麼樣
能夠從一支火箭
做40次
然後
我們就需要找
更多
可以在這一方面
有專長的人
那時候
他們看我的背景
他就說
你就是做量產的
做食物量產
你就做食物量產
你就做自動化生產。
你對生產
比我們大部分的人。
都瞭解
OK
那你來
趕快
開始來做
這個飛行9號的
這個擴張過程
所以那個時候
他們為什麼
從這個英朗的
這個需求開始
2013年是看到了什麼。
決定在那一年
要開始擴張
也不是從那一年
開始擴張
也就是
接下來英朗
從一開始
他就決定說
火箭
並不應該
OK
是火箭
火箭並不應該是火箭。
對
火箭
大家都覺得火箭
是一個高達上
火箭是一個
哇
我們就叫
我們在這個
無城市裡面
這樣的進攻跑段
就看
特殊的人才能做火箭。
OK
的確
火箭
它的規格
是比所有東西之上。
這是的確的
但是英朗的認知
是即使在這樣之下。
火箭也不應該
OK
是這樣的生產模式。
他覺得跟造型
特斯拉沒什麼本質。
區別
這個你做的
非常非常的對點
就是
特斯拉
那個時候
跟SpaceX是一個。
姐妹公司
就像兩個姐妹
在同一個家庭裡面。
同一個家長
我可以總是
喜歡比較
姐姐今天做什麼事情。
妹妹怎麼樣
怎麼等等的
所以呢？
我覺得英朗
身為兩家公司的CEO。
多多少少
有這樣的一個Cross-over。
所以他是姐姐
你們是妹妹是嗎
誰是姐姐
誰是妹妹
我認為我們應該是妹妹。
但是最主要是
變壞體來這個東西。
OK
對
而且我們是
他會真的比較嗎
他會跟SpaceX。
這是好問題
不會這樣比較
但是
我們就是後面知道的。
他在當時不知道
但是後面
因為我們反而認識。
跟特斯拉人
我現在的夥伴
也是特斯拉的
他們會說
其實在當下的時候。
英朗是非常明顯的。
英朗是非常偏SpaceX。
特斯拉人這樣感官。
他們覺得說
SpaceX
就像是在這個家庭裡面。
OK
就是一個
很會花錢
然後就是最
最寵壞的妹妹
你知道嗎
然後
很辛苦的這個姐姐。
我就需要去賺
很多很多的錢
OK
為了來支柱這個妹妹。
我可以說
需要這所的開發
然後妹妹
得到了都是比姐姐。
好很多的東西
等等
所以他會在特斯拉裡面。
念SpaceX
但是他會在SpaceX。
念特斯拉嗎
也不會
其實這兩家公司的規格。
它不一樣
所以他沒有
早期的時候
沒有太多交集的
你說坐汽車跟坐火箭。
OK
但是
鷹朗的目標是
希望把火箭
像汽車化這樣做
但是你必須承認
這兩個的規格
還是差非常非常
非常多的
這兩個規格
能從SKEU
去直觀的量
好嗎
不能直觀
從SKEU的直觀。
但是對一個東西的。
精細
Do
OK
這個的
就
我記得
一個更簡單的
解釋吧？
就是說
大家會覺得說
火箭是什麼東西
OK
就是火箭是什麼
最後你發出火箭
到這個地方
但是意味著什麼東西。
為什麼火箭
大家說這麼高的規格。
怎麼等等的
火箭
象徵的
也就是你今天想像。
你今天開始
從這裡開車
到洛杉磯
你開始一路開
開到你洛杉磯
你的目的地的點
也就是你剛好
開進你的家門口的時候。
你最後一滴油
剛剛好用完了
這個就是火箭
就是它是一個
完完全全精算
你想想看
你在這麼長途的旅行中。
可以發生任何的事情。
等等的這種風土
等等的
但是精算
到時候我確定
你到這個點的時候。
你的燃料
最後一滴用完了
因為你的燃料
如果生一堆的話
你就是一個爛火箭。
你的效率就極端的低。
火箭的最高境界
就是能夠把這整個東西。
控管到這種的精準度。
那你覺得任何車子。
有辦法一本達到
這種的精準度嗎
車子的目的地是不一樣的。
是不一樣的
但是就算
就是在這個車子
跟你說
它有653mI
我可以在剩下的時候。
你覺得它有多精準。
這種長途的圈
但這是火箭
跟SpaceX
跟特斯拉
這樣的就是
車齊跟火箭之間
所要求的這個東西。
我現在講另外一點。
你從SpaceX。
從洛杉磯開到
從現在開到洛杉磯。
這個路程上面
OK
你還要經歷過一個。
最極端的一個環境。
OK
它可能熱的時候
給幾百度
冷的時候幾百度
而且可以一天裡面。
變幾百度這樣的溫差。
然後給一個
在全真空環境
所以它是一個
規格上面的確跟
車子的要求
是非常非常不一樣的。
一個產品
但是即使在這個之下。
銀廊認為
我們回歸到
SpaceX要達到的這個目標。
我們如果要能夠
真正開脫宇宙
真正的把這個東西。
做成一件事
那火箭即使這麼高的規格。
必須把它做成
上車子這樣的一個簡單化。
它竟然這麼難
需要這麼高的精度。
你在開始負責
這個費用9號之前。
你是沒有這個
任何這個火箭相關背景的。
哪怕你在管費用號的時候。
它其實也不直接相關。
對不對
沒錯
那你
我覺得這樣一看到這個。
就崩潰
你怎麼接受這個工作呢？
你是這個團隊的負責人嗎。
我真的團隊負責人。
每一個人都能
對
這是一個非常好問題。
所以
你說
今天要找任何一個人。
我問你
你覺得好了
你今天去找一個專家。
你覺得在這個世界上有幾個。
真的能夠符合
你想要找這個專家。
他可以從他那個團隊。
promote一個人。
Yes
That's true。
但是這個團隊裡面。
也是
二十幾歲
從好大學
這樣畢業
很聰明的一些人
所以Sveyside的定義。
他在乎一個人
能夠在短時間裡面。
能夠吸收多少
能夠成長多少
能夠
能夠適應多少
比起
你以前過去幾十年這樣的經驗。
為什麼
因為經驗的確能夠幫助你在。
很多事情這樣
在一開始起點
有比更多人更高的高點。
但是在Sveyside這家公司裡面。
他從來沒有把自己定義成。
是一家其他的公司。
怎麼說
在很多其他的公司裡面。
你可能一年
我跟老闆說
我給這個項目
省了百分之十
百分之二十
百分之三十
OK這樣的效率
你了不起了
升級
OK
加獎金
你跟英朗說
我今天給這個項目。
增加了百分之三十。
OK這樣的效率
依然會讓你滾出去。
滾出去
你根本沒有在思考。
哦
他真的會說滾出去嗎。
我等一下要說這個故事。
但是Sveyside。
OK的這個標準
你如果沒有從背脊。
也就是這個東西
是一個十背脊
也就是在英文叫做Magnet。
就是十背脊
或者百背脊
這樣的跳躍的話
你根本就沒有在做你的事情。
這樣的一個起點
OK那回歸到你剛剛問題。
那他會叫你滾出去嗎。
OK那英朗呢？
跟英朗的溝通是什麼樣子。
因為我們身為高管。
我們常常要跟英朗溝通。
聽說過
一點點
對不對
大家都覺得說對英朗溝通。
是一個很酷的事情。
哇你天天去英朗
是不是天天跟英朗high five。
OK很酷
英朗現在是任命人。
英朗怎麼樣
那英朗只會跟你開會。
開三件事情
第一件事情
你的東西遲到了
第二件事情
你的東西做不出來。
第三件事情
你的東西需要更多的錢。
所以三件事情跟英朗開發。
從來沒有任何一個東西。
是一個很簡單的回憶。
像我在跟你在聊天這樣的事情。
都是一個非常高壓。
很難的一個態度
那所以呢？
那在一根英朗裡面。
英朗呢？
是一個極端聰明的一個人。
英朗也常常說
它是水塞的總工程師。
總設計師
你可能會覺得說
這是一個很扯的事情。
我可以自己
我可以創意家公司。
我可以自己做CEO。
現在也要說
啊我自己也是這個家工。
火箭是我設計的
OK等等
他從一個SVS裡面的人講說。
這句話其實也沒有那麼的錯。
沒有那麼的錯
但還是錯的
嗯還有其實嚴格來講沒有錯。
OK為什麼說總設計師是什麼。
總設計師決定整個公司的方向。
整個設計的這個規格。
OK所有公司大大小小的事情。
OK的確最後一個拍板的。
的確是英朗
所以說他自己說
他自己火箭的總設計師。
或者這家公司的總工程師。
因為其實也嚴格來講。
沒有那麼的錯
嗯
OK但是在這之下。
OK你在跟英朗溝通的時候。
對英朗會問你對不對。
反正英朗呢？
處於一個非常簡單的。
一個低邏輯的角度出發。
因為他會問你一個。
非常簡單直接的事情。
OK很多時候呢？
在這個行業裡面的事情。
在行業裡面走的人。
OK肯定會覺得就是。
就懵了
OK就是你在說什麼。
OK但是你如果從一個。
英朗低邏輯的角度來講。
你就差不多會了解他。
OK也就是能夠回答說。
英朗呢會不會比較。
SpaceX跟Tesla這件事情。
英朗常常最喜歡的事情。
就可以覺得提的是說。
喂我做一台Model S。
或者我後面我做一台Model 3。
了不起了
全部的加起來成本就這麼多的錢。
那你今天為什麼一個火箭的引擎。
或者一個火箭的這個部位。
你需要OK是這麼多的錢。
並且呢你的效率是這麼的低。
這是一個很簡單
就英朗就直接的一個對比。
怎麼回答他這個問題。
我們是火箭啊？
我覺得很多公司
你可以講我們是火箭。
這樣的一個問題
那英朗就會直接問。
問更細的
我舉一個例子吧？
我覺得這個例子
可能會比較清晰
我那個時候反正在練英九號。
反正他關了以後
反正一個一個部門。
一個一個部門這個部門。
反正反正所有
給大大小小練英九號上面的部位。
基本上後面都是我管的。
那我那個時候呢管了一個部門。
OK是飛英九號上面的一個。
超級高壓桶
OK這個東西
反正就是做的那麼大。
給兩米差不多長了一個高壓桶。
你說高壓桶是什麼樣。
就是跟瓦斯桶一樣。
就是什麼了不起的東西。
OK那高壓桶
我給你一個具體的例子。
你自己開車
你相不相信輪胎
是一個很高壓的東西。
就是你打開輪胎
這樣的聲音
是的
我不知道你們體驗到。
OK那輪胎的壓力呢？
是40 PSI
OK那這個高壓桶。
我們在做的這個火箭。
OK是上萬級
這樣的一個同樣的一個 PSI。
所以你可以搞定
它是一個巨無霸
一個超級的一個高壓桶。
然後並且又要輕
OK你看火箭要鎖得輕。
所以你要輕
又要這個全世界最耐。
最耐壓的一個產品。
那大家都可以想像。
這是一個全世界最大的一個工藝。
你不能夠失去任何的一點。
因為你任何一點
它這個東西就會爆炸。
是一顆炸彈
那這個東西呢？
在水塞以往呢？
都是直接跟彩鍋商。
直接收買的
OK這個東西很貴。
因為你想想看
要能夠做一個
所有完全無瑕吃
然後又能夠高壓那麼輕的東西。
彩鍋商跟你說
這個東西一個一年。
一個十幾萬元
十幾萬美元
十幾萬美元就算了。
OK最主要是彩鍋商。
一年說十幾萬美元。
我了不起了
我一年就能夠給你幾個。
你這神經病
這麼高精的東西
我怎麼可能
能夠做你跟我一樣的這個數字。
所以你一年要多少個。
就要你發射40次。
這種飛影手號這樣吃下。
那一年聽完這個以後。
就覺得說是超扯的。
我們就只要一年發射40次。
你就跟不上了
那你就滾吧？
我們自己開發
所以一年就直接把這個東西。
丟過來給我們
你們這個東西
反正你們就是想
反正這個東西
我們要自己做了
而且我們要做
全業界裡面最厲害的。
高壓桶
絕對不能夠
就只能做一樣的
所以我們就自己回去。
反正做了一段時間。
然後做回來了
好
我們把這個成品
帶回來給英朗了
我們的確做出來了。
自家的
而且能比業界的
成本低90%
而且量能夠跟得上。
這個飛影手號
那我們自己非常非常的自豪。
我們覺得說我們自己。
全世界最牛的一個團隊。
OK 沒有人能夠做。
或許是一個奇蹟
我趕緊自己回頭看。
怎麼做出來的呢？
我覺得過去這個心酸。
我們可以再講
三個小時
我們就不講了這個東西。
但是是非常非常多的時間的投入。
跟這樣的這個疊帶。
反正最終做出來了。
OK 這個
那
但是做出來的第一點。
到英朗這個桌面的時候。
你猜英朗怎麼回答的。
Good
我覺得他連Good這個字都沒有講。
他也沒有說你bad。
Fine
甚至都沒有講這個事情。
OK
Yes 就是一般人都會講這句話。
Good bad fine OK 對不對。
英朗第一句話來問。
你有沒有看過可樂慣的生產。
就沒有 沒有 get it。
就所有你看我們剛才講的。
講那麼多
給我們做多厲害多厲害的。
好
給英朗看
你有沒有看過可樂慣的生產。
自他唯一的一個回答。
那我們就說
OK
我們當然知道可樂慣的生產。
但是英朗
你在講什麼東西
OK
我們知道
Yes
我們有看過
然後呢？
那英朗說
這個可樂慣的生產。
你想想看你在做的這個東西。
是一個耐壓的產品。
可樂慣
從第一原理
也是一個耐壓的產品。
那為什麼可樂慣
可以在一分鐘裡面。
生產上千個可樂慣。
然後以幾分錢這樣的角度。
然後去做這個東西。
你今天這個東西
即使你做了所有的改革。
還是一樣
就是這個量跟這個價格。
你們是不是還有待。
在改進了這個空間。
這個呢？
其實就是一個很簡單。
很直接
跟英朗這樣的一個對話。
那也是一個
很代表英朗的一個對話。
你說英朗是不是一個不好的人。
他會破你冷水
他會說你很嚴格
這樣不講理的一個老闆。
也不是
但是呢？
他提出了一點
就是說
從嚴格嚴格工程的角度。
你有辦法去反駁他嗎。
你
從第一原理思維
沒有辦法去反駁他。
當然你可以說
不管個火箭高深的這個東西。
這差太遠
你也扯太遠了
但是如果你朝他這個。
終極的這個境界來講。
這兩個東西是一樣的。
從一個物理的角度。
OK是一樣的東西。
那這個就是英朗
跟所有團隊的這個溝通。
就是說你說
他會把你叫滾出去嗎。
他會這樣你才會摔。
你們是全部怎麼樣。
英朗呢其實是一個很平的一個人。
他也知道你做了什麼事情。
沒做了什麼事情
但是呢他會持續的。
OK再把你推到
你不知道
你可以到了一個境界。
那你們走出那個會議室以後。
還在繼續優化嗎
我們還是繼續優化。
當然你從一個火箭的這個產品。
不可能到一個可樂罐。
OK這個東西
我覺得還是一個
但是呢他的確給你的一個。
一個想法
OK好的確從這個角度。
我們還沒有辦法再擠出一些。
我們之前沒有想過的東西。
和英朗他會有任何的振訪。
可以嗎他會鼓勵你嗎。
從來沒有嗎
他是一個沒有任何情緒價值的老闆嗎。
他的情緒價值呢？
跟我覺得很多
所有的老闆或者CEO。
我覺得很不一樣
OK那大家呢？
我可能之前說
大家跟隨英朗
是因為英朗是一個很真的一個人。
OK他很相信他自己的東西。
那他也自己也知道。
他在講什麼事情
對不對那他自己一個。
把自己永遠放在最前衛。
那跟你一起奮鬥的一個人。
所以他其實是從
一個心裡面在那邊。
在領導這整個團隊的一個人。
OK那
你說他
會不會去罵你
還是會不會是
鼓掌你其實英朗
是從一個人為上面。
他是一個很平的一個人。
很平的一個人
他沒有等級意識
他沒有太多的喜怒哀樂。
其實他
你可以嚴格講他可能是一個很無聊的一個人。
雖然你可以看
英朗可能現在比較風趣了。
在大眾面前
我覺得他經過十幾年以後。
練習出來的
他是一個深度
他是一個很平的一個人。
沒有什麼情緒波動。
對他生氣的時候
他也不會摔桌子
對他開心的時候
他會像小孩子一樣開心。
怎麼像小孩子一樣開心。
我覺得這個很酷
跟你在那邊開一個冷笑話。
等等
但是他就是一個很。
就像一個小孩子一樣。
你可以很明顯的知道。
有時候
因為他就是
他蠻真情
會釋放出來
你也可以感受得到。
全公司在努力
都會覺得說
我希望你拿完去英朗開心。
的一個點
但是他不會表揚你。
他只是會自己開心。
他會覺得說對
像我們做這個高壓。
我們把這個東西
我們甚至做出來一個像。
全自動化的地方
就是我在SwissX可能最大的一個計畫。
我可以跟他
就要幾百萬美金
我們真的就把這個。
像汽車一樣把全自動化的生產。
真的就做出來了
全世界的第一個
怎麼高規格量化的生產量。
做出來了
英朗那個時候在看我的這個表格。
當然你在準備給英朗的時候。
你是充足的準備了。
那個PBT大概改了22次。
你跟他開會多少會。
我跟他呢？
我嚴格來講
你說每個禮拜會不會開會。
不一定
但是有事情的時候。
可能一個禮拜不只開一次會。
英朗開會不是為了開會。
英朗不會跟你說我每個禮拜。
跟你在那邊開會定期。
就是你跟我update什麼東西。
英朗只會給你開三個會。
就是我剛剛講的這個事情。
我剛剛沒有跟你講話。
其實你就是做得不錯。
你就繼續做吧？
就是這樣一個定義。
他色了的人跟我說他會罵人啊？
他罵人很兇
他從來沒有罵過你們嗎。
有啊？
可是他罵人不是很兇。
他罵人比兇更恐怖。
直接開了
這個東西有時候我很早。
其實社會高管說是親眼體驗到的。
這樣不會怎麼樣
但是那個時候在那個場景很明顯。
就是我們在過一個這個設計。
對不對
那也是一個公司一個也算滿資深的一個工程師。
我可以再做這個整個他的報告。
然後給英朗報告進度。
當然進度不如預期。
所以英朗開始跟他在那邊對峙了。
你為什麼不做這樣。
你為什麼不這樣
講到最後
那個人接來一句
英朗你要做的這個東西不可能。
你不能跟他說這麼說。
你要求的這個東西不可能。
做不到
英朗當下我印象非常非常的深刻。
因為那時候是我身為高管以後。
跟他開了一個比較早期的一個會。
他直接來一句
很淡定的
說好
那我接受你的辭呈。
你想想看
你我在這個同樣這個房間裡面。
我們就是高管坐在後面。
在聽這個報告
然後把最後來這一句。
好
你覺得接下來的30秒是怎麼樣。
沉默
空氣凝結
差不多
我覺得是反正是
能夠說時間這樣停頓。
可能就是那種感覺吧？
你有看到那個同事走出來的時候的表情嗎。
英朗同學那個同事就直接說ok。
他就走出去了
嗯
就這樣子
就很淡定
但你說這是英朗看什麼。
有沒有在那邊拍桌子。
有沒有在那邊丟椅子。
有沒有在那邊你是全界最大的廢物。
他沒有咆哮
他從來沒有咆哮
他不會咆哮
他就說我就接受你的辭呈。
外界很多時候都會覺得。
他是一個暴君
其實你看到的不是。
但外界的確很多人直言。
他的確在一些場景下。
他是
因為他是一個
像我說的他是一個非常真情那個人。
他不太會
克制他自己心裡想的。
對他想要跟你開個冷笑話。
就跟你開個冷笑話。
這樣家人有時候可以離開他的時候。
有時候他也會像小孩子一樣的這樣的反應。
你剛才講了
就是公司為什麼敢用你。
作為費英九號的
首席製造工程師
從你的角度你來到這個崗位。
你面對的是一攤什麼樣的事情。
我覺得肯定頭都炸了。
從一個沒有做過火箭的人。
然後開始我要負責一個。
火箭的項目
是其實很簡單
很多的確在費英九號的項目的人。
都可以對費英九號。
各個的工程非常非常內行的工程師。
非常聰明的人
也非常有乾淨的一些工程師。
年輕的工程師
那他們的確
很多人是畢業完
第一份工作以後
就可以加入SpaceX。
所以他們從來沒有做過生產的事情。
所以當我把生產做好。
我們要做40台火箭。
我們現在邏輯來思考。
4台火箭需要什麼。
我們開始把一個表格這樣發出來。
4台火箭生徑的時候。
你需要在這個實驗點裡面。
做什麼
這很基礎
這不是理所當然的事情嗎。
可是很多時候
這些工程師非常聰明。
可是可能很多時候。
就需要一些整合
那時候我就在做整合這個角色。
你看Mask會把Model 3。
Model X跟火箭來對比。
你覺得費英九號
相當於如果是車的序號的話。
他到了Model幾。
費英九號一定是一個。
不要說SpaceX。
我認為航空航年界的。
Model T
Model T呢？
Model T是福特。
那個時候在
一早期在顛覆
整個汽車產業的時候的第一個產品。
把汽車第一次大量化。
Model T
我認為費英九號更實際的。
是Model T。
Model T
差了100年
你說現在新建的整個規劃。
跟費英九號
是完完全全是兩個級別。
新建能到什麼時刻呢？
如果類比汽車產業。
新建嗎
按照英文所說的
他是希望一步能夠跨到Model 3。
但是我認為
這個有點懸
我就能夠把Model S。
可能就不錯了
我們看時間吧？
從歷史看未來
費英九號總共花了。
10年的時間
從開發
一直把這個回收
回收
將地質火箭
然後這個歷程碑
那
新建花了整整
一半的時間
做到一半
做到這個歷程碑
在歷史去推未來的話。
那或許
新建能夠在未來的兩三年內。
能夠達到這個境界。
你覺得它能達到Model系列嗎。
我認為是可以持續。
這個觀測的
以我們對新建
然後以對整個
所有我們還在那邊。
奮鬥的朋友們
跟我們的
直接feedback。
我覺得是
你作為費英九號的。
首席製造工程師
你們從內部視角來跟我們講講。
這個費英的
它的發展
它有什麼樣的里程碑。
整個費英的系列
可以
費英其實大家都覺得說。
費英九號
這個名字
可是費英九號
兩個大的里程碑
第一個
就是費英九號
能夠達到回收
2005年的回收。
這是第一個里程碑。
就是第一個費英九號能夠在另外一層。
然後第二個
也就是在這個回收以後。
能夠大量
持續量化生產
並且能夠持續這樣完成這個任務。
我覺得這是第二個里程碑。
所以我覺得費英九號就是兩個里程碑。
第一
就是費英九號一開始發展發射成功進軌道。
不是一件事
發射成功進軌道
成功的回收了
這是第一個很重要的里程碑。
在這個里程碑之上。
能夠做到一整個系統。
能夠不只能夠回收。
並且能夠量化
這是真正的費英九號。
最後的一個里程碑。
大概在什麼時間
兩年內
這三年內
事情很密集
我們在
我常常跟很多人講。
SpaceX的這個開發史。
你看
SpaceX是2022年創立。
那2022年
他可能花了第一個十年。
2022到2012年。
完成了所謂的這個Startup的0到1。
那我們
加入SpaceX。
然後到在奮鬥這些年。
OK 就是所謂的。
SpaceX的這個第二部曲。
OK 就是1到1000。
那現在呢？
SpaceX
OK 到從1222年。
OK 到後面
就整個平台
然後再加上整個太空產業的開發。
這是SpaceX第三部曲。
就是第三代人竟然來做的事情。
費英九號進入了成功和失敗。
當然先是失敗更多。
這個故事能不能給大家講講。
從2015年第一次降落。
OK
回收成功
重要力成碑
那你可以想像
那是你參與了 對吧？
當然參與了 對
那在那個當下
你可以想像在費英九號。
那個時候能夠做到這件事情。
其實已經是在業界裡面。
非常非常先進的火箭了。
在所有業界 不管是NASA的規格。
不管是ULA 不管是。
反正全世界任何的火箭規格。
費英九號在那個當下。
已經是工人非常先進的火箭。
但是在那個當下
2015年 2016年。
我們接連發射了兩次。
OK的失敗
並且兩次的失敗
都跟我的部門有關。
因為那個時候我說了。
我管了所有費英九號的部位的部門。
只要不是可
基本上都是我的部門。
所以都跟我的部門有關。
那個時候我會說
大衛認為說
你知道一開始費英九號到2008年。
這是費的最困難的時候。
那費的最困難的時候。
其實就是在2015年。
2016年這個時候。
剛剛經歷了一次成功。
不只經歷一次成功。
經歷了多次成功
並且你已經在整個業界裡面。
是最前面的時候
你失敗了
你失敗的時候
現在問題來了
你已經是整個業界裡面。
大家對標的一個目標。
你已經是跑在整個業界前面。
你失敗了
你失敗的時候
你問誰這個問題
出了問題
那個時候在發射台上。
瞬間爆炸了
所有人那個時候都認為。
這是費英九號最完美的一個版本。
可能再進階了
我們改進過所有最完美的一個版本。
突然間失敗了
所有業界認為這是最完美。
我們也不知道
所有沒有人知道
所以在你一個不知不知的一個環境之下。
那你也知道說
你的錢也就只有這麼多。
你要不要辦法解決這個問題。
整個公司
可能就是在
當下就解職
其實我其實在
第五年一六年的時候。
我在SpaceX裡面最低。
不要說我全公司
最大困難的時候
每天的表情是什麼樣呢？
一樣的表情其實
跟它平時的時候是一模一樣的。
這也是我給英郎跟所有。
我覺得SpaceX存在。
在這個的當下
大家不會覺得
只有什麼不一樣
只有什麼
OK我們有一個很困難的困難。
沒錯
的確是一個公司
很困難的事情
但是我們就是反正。
還是一樣按照我們的方式。
一一的去解決這個問題。
英郎那個時候
你看這個時候
發生問題了
第一件事會幹什麼。
誰負責
這件事情把它找出來。
把它砍了
OK我們把這個人砍了。
所以這個問題解決了。
我們可以繼續在這檔上錢。
對NASA可沒有那麼簡單。
你要沒有辦法能夠。
找到這個東西的一個原點。
它就是整個
管理SpaceX再多抄錢。
你就是不准飛
你不飛沒錢
沒錢你覺得在SpaceX。
那麼龐大體系
带作的钱在那个时候其实是最丰险的时候。
就在量化的时候
你倒是压力大吗？
你的部门出问题
压力大到
我那个时候其实在那之前啊？
我很久没有生病
我刚刚可能跟早期跟你说我再。
回归看来我人最累的时候。
OK可能是在我第一份工作。
我给做三个小时完成所有的每天八个小时就可以回家。
然后这样
那是我最累的时候。
在Spacesize每一天。
OK基本上是996。
OK大家认为说中国996可以跟全球竞争。
那大家可能没有想到是马斯克也有个996。
在美国
OK那
中国可能有一些
比较便宜的劳工
或许能够在生产上面有优势或者更厉害的工程师。
对那Spacesize组织一些完全免费的工程师。
基本上净免费的工程师我以时间这样处理他们。
你们没有家团工资。
我完全没有家团工资。
但每一个人基本上12个小时6天是个蛮基本的一个东西。
这是美国劳工法
这不是Spacesize发明的。
大家觉得在美国生产是一个不肯的事情。
对那美国的确有分。
对不对就是你是一个。
Orly的劳工
fine你有加班费你有实行。
那你要是一个工程师你要是一个管理人员。
他们是完全没有受限的就是。
你是一个责任制的。
你完成你的事情
你需要多少时间完成你的事情你就花多少时间。
你一个小时能够做完事情。
非常好回家睡觉任你开心。
你要需要24个小时那你就留着吧？
OK
那就是Spacesize那个时候的状况。
最后来找的问题跟远了吧？
那时候都是很细微的问题。
我们经历到了几个月。
长期不断
所有在一个
未知下
然后真的就靠自己直觉。
然后测试所有我们的可能性。
其实运气也是一部分。
因为你说那个时候有办法在这么短时间内。
测试所有的这些
原因吗不可能
你那个时候只能够靠直觉。
跟
跟靠你的运气
就真的给你猜中了。
那个时候基本上就到了这个阶段。
那我真的被我们猜中了。
那的确是一个非常非常边缘。
设计的就是在
所有设计产品里面大家最怕的。
就是我们未知未知。
OK这个点
那真的被我们弄出来了。
就是这个点
然后经过反正这个地方的改变。
那飞营9号
在这之后
我说英文叫Nog On Wits。
OK希望不会再发生。
但是到目前为止600多次的发射。
没有什么问题
我看到你之前跟媒体回忆过。
就是那一天的发射是2015年的6月28号。
是马斯克斯日式的生日。
然后那一天你迟到了。
他有一种不祥的预感。
你那天为什么迟到了。
那因为是第一次
第一次发生
就总有两次
对
那次也没有所谓迟到。
我那一般是很早上班的。
一般我喜欢找
找进公司
然后希望能够找出公司。
但是我喜欢早上的时候工作。
对 那个时候我比早。
我比一般的时候就晚睡了一点。
对 那我进公司的时候。
反正公司这个发射已经在进行当中了。
我就就刚刚好
就是滑雷
我可以进来刚好看到了。
对 那个时候
反正我就反正问周边的人。
怎么样 今天发射怎么样。
我才刚到
他说看起来不妙
我可以看这个书
我就哇 这玩意
这可都是
就是这一句话
看起来不妙
那的确在非常短的时间以后。
就火箭就出事了
在这种时刻会偷偷去看英诺表情吗？
每次发射的现场
也不会 因为英朗那个时候。
其实它就坐在发射的控制室里面。
就是SpaceX的设计。
如果去SpaceX。
SpaceX有一个。
反正SpaceX是一个最大的组装厂。
那它在做组装厂前面有一个控制台。
那这个控制台是像NASA。
这样的一个控制台。
就是所有这些上面的这个火箭的指标。
那当然是比NASA更先进。
就是看起来像一个21世纪的这样的控制台。
然后就反正所有SpaceX的员工就围绕了这个控制台。
然后在那边一起观况。
观看这个发射的这个进展。
对 那当然英朗是坐在里面。
对 然后在发在最前面。
这个部分
对 所以我没有看到英朗的表情。
我要坐在这前面
但是可以想象
对不对 在你的生日里面发生这种事情。
应该是一个蛮深刻的一个体验。
6月28号
你为什么会从VACF离开。
我在2018年的年底的时候。
就是真的年底
你觉得12月31号。
那一天记得都好清楚。
12月31号
为什么会记得这么清楚。
因为这是一个反英朗对全公司发了一个全公司的一个email。
就说OK 好 这件事。
你如果今天
可以下单买一台特斯拉。
并且在今天立刻取货。
OK 我就送你全送驾驶。
在10月2018年10月31号。
那个时候我影响深刻。
OK 好 那个时候在那个之前。
我其实也没有想过电车。
OK 我开的车很满意。
我也没有试过电车。
我没有想过要改车。
但是那个时候英朗这样说的这句话。
那我就说 OK 好。
那 fine
好 那特斯拉
OK 不是那么？
反正在经历过一些比较困难的这个状况。
那我们就反正就帮助我们的解决公司。
对 那个时候反正我觉得下了单。
那我们买一台特斯拉。
Model 3
也是我全世界第一台新车。
那并且是在电车
我在领车我开始开那台车的Sana。
我就有一个非常非常深刻的体验。
可以从一个机械工程的角度。
我认为电车这个平台。
OK 是它不会是一个噱头。
它也不会是一个特斯拉专有的一个平台。
就这个东西在从各个角度上面。
都比现在的这个游车。
OK 有可能有一个更大的一个一个潜力。
OK 所以那个时候我就觉得说哇。
我开着这个体验让我感觉。
如果有一天我如果觉得说哪一个机会。
比SpaceX还要更大。
原来一定是在电车产业里面。
所以那个时候当下我就决定说OK fine。
我离开SpaceX以后我就要加入一个电车公司。
刚好这个机会在2019年时候呈现了。
那个时候在LA
就一瓶特斯拉一瓶SpaceX。
去加入一个早期的一个特斯拉。
一个电池公司
给专门做大型的电池给卡车跟商用车使用。
对 所以那个时候我就。
觉得说这个东西非常有意义。
反正就加入他们的行业。
所以离开了SpaceX。
你对火箭没有执念吗？
怎么说执念呢？
就是这个事情没实现我不能走。
这个事情永远实现不完。
你觉得说飞影酒号。
这个有一个据点
是不是星间是不是有一个据点。
但是你如果回归到。
就是SpaceX这个终止。
就是外太空还太大。
为什么我们一定要留在这个星球上面。
如果已经这样赴标的话。
听说星间算有星间只是第一步。
你觉得SpaceX现在有星间有星链。
有这些什么太空数据中。
这些才是刚刚开始。
就SpaceX是要开拓宇宙。
然后它常常在讲火星。
因为火星只是第一步。
第一步
每次我升星就是太空还有非常非常长的路。
那也是一个接下来一个非常充满想象。
并且充满商业价值的一个空间。
如果让你给外行解释一下。
这个航天的产业量。
从上游到下游
你会把它描述成哪些环节。
好我觉得简单来讲。
上游你可以讲就是简单来讲是一个苦活。
OK你说的这个火箭的建造火箭的开发。
火箭的发射卫星的建造。
给太空站的建造开发等等这都是上游。
就是你们做的那个环节。
就是我们做的这个环节。
那当你把你这个东西发射到太空以后。
诶你觉得没事了吗？
OK那在上面
OK卫星跟卫星之间。
OK这样的控管
卫星需要的调整卫星需要的管理。
卫星需要把数据传输到地面。
这整条的这个控管。
我们叫做mid layer。
这就可能是中游
那下游是什么？
下游就是说OK好。
就是一个最简单的一个so what。
你要把火箭飞上去太空在上面了。
给卫星在上面了
那然后呢你能够做什么？
OK那我觉得现在最明显的一个。
就是所谓的应用程。
那现在最明显的当然是星链。
OK那我觉得星链啊不管你我。
OK我不知道你会不会在飞机上体验过。
给这个无所不在
高高速网络的这样的连接。
我觉得是一个才是一个刚刚的一个起点。
那你说在全世界布局没有一点。
嗯嗯对一个完全无缝隙的一个侦测。
OK这个对AI对接下来。
这个整个 physical ed 一个开发。
这个全新的一个数据库。
那你我们再想大一点。
在这个低轨这个赛道。
只有卫星吗？
那能不能做一些更大的这个东西。
这个空间是一个比地球大好几倍的一个空间。
那有什么东西在地球上。
是可以在地球外
可以做比地球上更好的东西。
什么呢？
分开来讲呢其实呢？
我们这个要回归到这个太空的这个独立的一个环境。
你说换一个太空有什么特别的地方。
太空是一个完全
真空
完全一个
也不能说他的高温低温他就是一个真空的一个环境。
那并且呢是一个无重力的一个环境。
那很多材料科学在这个环境里面。
OK是可以开发出一些完完全全在地球上开发不出来的东西。
我简单来讲一个最简单的一个东西。
也就是一个球
你觉得开发一颗球有什么问题。
OK我们天天在那边踢一颗球。
在那边篮球什么这么太多球。
太空有什么厉害的球。
在地球上你要生产出一颗完美的球状。
OK其实在一个机械工程上是一个非常高的一个工艺。
可是在太空他就是一个瞬间的一个东西。
任何东西在太空无重力状态下。
还完完全全就是一个最完美的一个球状。
OK好那你说最完美的球状能做什么？
好那大家想象在这个里面。
OK或许第一个应用。
在一个人类的一个新的一个工程的延长膜。
OK希望在对于失明的人。
在失利有问题的人。
这个完美完美武下的一个服刑。
在地球上可能需要花五笔的工艺。
才能够做出来的事情。
在太空是非常非常轻松的事情。
这是第一点
OK太空我们刚刚说了。
在这种无重力状态下。
在材料科学上面你还能够开发什么？
我们现在在关注的一家公司。
希望利用太空这种独特的环境。
在开发下一端的这个晶圆。
现在大家不是说吗？
OK晶片都缺晶片。
我需要晶片更多的晶片。
更好的晶片更高效能的晶片。
那晶片的起点是晶圆。
你的晶圆的纯度
跟你的晶圆的这个亮度。
OK能够决定你后面。
就是他的表现
对 这一款
对 所以我们在看这家公司。
就是运用在这个SpaceX平台上面。
怎么样做下一代
超越
就是现在你说的看了晶片的晶圆。
你说的这是一个创业公司。
这其实是你现在做投资做的事情。
你在寻找这样的创业公司。
那它怎么基于SpaceX的平台去做这件事情呢？
因为现在还没有这个先决条件。
它没有SpaceX的那样的资源。
它跟SpaceX是什么关系呢？
它需要跟它合作吗？
这是跟它合作
然后另外一点我们投资里面。
其实我们一个很底层的逻辑。
就是你看太空产业。
SpaceX在过去的20年。
扭力开发出一个像苹果。
这样的一个新的一个平台。
所以你在太空接下来的。
所有大大小小的创业。
你可以就把它纳飞文两种。
一种
就是所谓的苹果链SpaceX链。
苹果链SpaceX链。
OK 你是顺着这个SpaceX。
你知道它的长期目标。
你知道它要做什么？
你也知道
就是里面在做这些事情的所有的这些人。
那你要非常相信它能做成。
OK 这一点
OK
然后你能申请它能做成。
你也确定知道它能做成。
这是有很多内部信息的人。
当然
是什么？
就是我们说的非常简单。
Android
就像苹果一样
对对对
我们反正在出自于这个产业里面的人。
他们在某一个细节。
某一个利益方
OK 他们有比
所有业界里面
非常非常艰深的这些逻辑。
那并且那我不
我SpaceX一定是像苹果一样。
它是一个吹支整合。
反正你要在我链里面。
你要跟我这样
在我这个大体系里面。
但是还有一个除了SpaceX以外。
很大的一个市场给全世界。
这是我们所谓的一个AndroidLin。
所以在这个行业里面。
你就要我们是这两个派系。
那在这个两个派系里面。
其实最核心的一批的创业者。
也是我们很关心的一批创业者。
像你刚刚讲到的
你怎么认识这些人。
你是不是里面的人。
其实就是我们所谓。
属称的这些新的这些英郎Mafia。
OK 这是我们的这些。
以前出自于SpaceX。
那一起共试过
也非常了解里面底层逻辑。
那也非常年轻
非常能干
并且OK 非常有任。
在这个领域里面
有独色的认知的一些人。
就是我们只是基金一个。
省大的一个底层的一个。
一个拍摄来源
太空的产业链
现在实际被点亮到多少了。
这个产业链还是一片狼海吗？
我觉得你看看
怎么样的一个时间点。
跟一个怎么样的一个规模。
在今天这个时间点。
我觉得你如果看看。
在今后太空可以是什么？
那当然这一切是狼海。
甚至你说OK
那如果就是晶级的。
OK 大家可能会对直接。
好 不要管那么多。
不要跟我讲星辰大海。
你就对地球现在
OK 上面已经有星链了。
那还能够玩什么？
但是你如果实际去想。
就地球上的这整个数据。
然后必须要刚刚我说的。
在天空外面的这个通讯网。
是一个远远超越地球上。
任何最先进的光迁。
通讯网的时候
那你把这个同样的数据算。
其实呢？
地球外面在10个星链。
可能都不够
做一个不恰当的产业队。
你觉得今天更像
比如说95年的互联网。
还是像10年的一通互联网。
但我觉得在你的理解下。
它可能是一个更广阔的一个市场。
对吧？
我认为是一个更大。
更有潜力的
而且这只是一个第一个点。
它是一个无限背什么？
先把这个东西做起来以后。
然后但这个东西间接了。
OK 能够带动又回归到地球。
因为我们不要讲
就是外台空以外
其他离我们太远的。
这个星辰大海的东西。
就回到地球
间接
在有这个网络以后。
对地球整个的生态的影响。
OK 那是一个第二波。
我认为的AWS
是一个第二什么的。
在一个
就像现在所有的
你说的这些移动物联网。
互联网
现在在AWS
就云上
OK 这些说应用。
我觉得现在才接下来。
才刚刚
甚至才刚刚开始
而且这个东西是有一个很多国。
给大家互相参与的一个部分。
比如以前的太空
可能是一个只有大国。
OK 才能够做的事情。
晚上美国
还是俄罗斯
还是中国
现在当今的今天
全世界有77个太空种树。
77个
目前大大小小的国家。
那这个东西只会增加。
这个东西只会增加。
只会增加
那它的主体还是国家吗？
还是平台
国家 平台
我觉得混在一起
但在一个太空
你的这个世界里面。
这是一个太空
我觉得最可能
最有意思的一个问题。
就是你当一个
比如说
你拥有一个太空站在上面。
那这个太空站
属于哪一个国家
对呀？
现在这是未知的
这是一个未知的
这也是一个
完全权利一个
带人去开发的一个领域。
那很广阔
所以我就想
可以把这个的想象空间。
可以打得很大
我觉得SpaceX。
在这个太空空间
会成为一个
多大的权力主体
SpaceX
是我常常跟很多投资人。
在争执的地方
我们远在开始
投资的时候
执着更早
我就常常跟大家在那边说。
我觉得
大家会问我说
你还有没有SpaceX的股票。
你有没有卖
什么等等的
你没有卖
我说我没有卖
我卖了一点
完全没卖
有卖了一点
你说
那为什么没卖
因为我觉得说
这个东西的估值
我们完全就还没有。
到它一点点的个可能性。
我觉得SpaceX。
是一个
就是在大航海时代里面。
Ease India Company。
那个时候
反正穿越
欧洲美洲
这样的一家
就是非常
不管是在财力
还是在所有的影响力。
非常大一家公司
而且现在才刚刚开始。
才刚刚开始
SpaceX竞争对手是谁。
你想要听马斯克的原话吗？
想
因为我们也在
SpaceX中国马斯克的一句话。
就是说
我们的竞争对手是谁。
那马斯克说
原话说
我们的竞争对手
是我们自己的竞争的速度。
OK 这个原话
但是
我们密切关注
中国航天的发展
原话
所以你怎么看中国航天。
我其实不知道怎么看中国人。
我知道说中国
举国之力
国家队
那并且中国航天
这几年所发展的速度。
跟所有的做的项目。
以我们在海外
非常受限的资讯之下。
我认为反正中国
周围来了太空最大的两个。
参与者 一定是中美。
这是非常明显的
当然今天
你可以说
SpaceX代表美国的航天。
非常的强
但是他在美国
这个主体的内部
他是怎么打破
就有的权力结构冲出来的。
我相信就有势力
肯定不想看到这一点。
他们在双方有这种权力。
非常真灵的时候吗？
我觉得在今天
这已经不是一个真灵的时候了。
当然
对不对
太明显了
但是你说像SpaceX。
刚出来的时候
对 你说在早期
我们加入SpaceX。
12年的时候
当对方向Poying。
有比你10倍多的资源。
跟无限的这种
对我们来看
像是无限的这样资金的时候。
对不对
他们有没有失智客客的。
可以打击SpaceX。
想要泼冷水
当然
OK 随时随客
印浪不是有一个
非常有名的这个interview吗？
就是他在这个interview里面。
他差点都哭了
为什么哭了呢？
因为那个时候
SpaceX在身为一家早期的公司。
在挣扎中
OK 想要快速地求挣扎。
并且想要对这个业界里面。
做出一些突破
OK 做出一些
真的把这个业界往前推。
OK
他在年轻的时候
非常上网的一个偶像。
就是BuzzOdron。
OK
Buzz是世界第二个登陆月球的人。
在阿姆施状那个时候。
对
Buzz讲了一句话。
对不对
就是他觉得说
SpaceX这家公司。
OK 最终会搞砸的。
OK 因为他们不知道。
他们在干嘛？
OK 就像是一批。
对不对
就是硅谷的这个牛仔。
OK 在他们认为说。
他们可以这种
很先营的东西
就可以去做这个太空。
OK 然后创新太空。
但是太空是一个
非常不容忍
任何的这种错误
非常精准 非常
OK 我们要把他。
非常慎重的一件事情。
OK 让我觉得在那个时候。
在早期的时候
基本上SpaceX就是面临这样的。
就是我在自己里面在推。
已经非常的累了
那我好不容易做成的事情。
还被外界这样的
在时时刻刻在那边泼冷水。
他也不是刻意的泼冷水。
因为对方有
你比10倍多的钱。
对 在华府
在所有的这些东西。
我觉得时时刻刻
反正我就靠钱
再给你倒出泼冷水。
但是最奇怪的是
这些人同样是在泼冷水。
那个时候在现在
也是同样一批人在那边说。
SpaceX是全界最厉害的公司。
我们就知道这是全界。
最大的独角兽等等的。
这些人
所以当然
SpaceX都经历过这些时刻。
他是在哪一刻
冲出了旧事业
你觉得是哪一年
我认为说
不能够说是满一年。
但是我认为说
这个东西与时做哪一年。
与时做SpaceX。
倒不如说是NASA。
之间的改变
在NASA
对SpaceX其实是一个。
全新的一个计划
也就是所谓的NASA。
在这个随在计划之前。
所有的太空计划
都是美国非常有名的一个。
就是对所有
不管对波音
还对所有的航空航天。
政府对大企业的单。
可能非常有名
就是叫Class Plus的一个单。
也就是说
我叫你做这个事情。
你要花多少时间
没问题
你要花多少钱
也没问题
至少我还确定你在这个钱上。
你还会赚钱
这样子的一个合约。
你想想在这个合约之下。
你觉得说
在传统这个企业
能够干出什么事情。
NASA
我觉得最明显的一个例子。
就是说我们现在不要说别的。
就是说现在
即将登月的两个火箭。
一个是NASA自己开发的SLS。
在2011年的时候启动。
花了差不多快20几年的时间。
比SpaceX差不多快5倍多的资金。
250亿美元
继续在Counting。
然后能够做出一支。
远远
OK就比不上新建。
不管是在载体
还是在回收等等
这样的一个火箭
这就是一个非常明显。
在一个所谓这个
美国太空时代
OK所产出的一个。
非常典型的
标榜的一个产品
NASA在意识到这个点之后。
成功了
OK推出了这个跟民营企业。
也就是说NASA。
从一个在2000年之前。
美国其实是一个
政府主导的一个太空program。
OK到了2000年以后。
其实是一个政府辅助。
OK的一个太空的一个计划。
那在这个计划
第一个最有标榜的。
OK就是CLD
也就是SpaceX。
第一个
就收到了这个
第一个的合约
然后能够订单
估计这个太空站
这就是所有新的NASA。
在一切的开始
那NASA在这个。
这个的学期上面学习到了。
OK这民营企业的这个效率。
然后培养出了SpaceX。
所以这个模型
现在开始到了所有这个计划。
OK包括了
现在在太空上面的。
这个国际太空站
2000年初的时候成立。
给花费了将近1000亿美元。
OK完成是全世界。
到目前为止还是最贵的建筑。
OK那2030年。
太空站即将退役
NASA决定说
我们不会再做新一代的太空站。
我们是像SpaceX的例子。
我们需要让民营企业开始接单。
所以这是一个
从NASA开始的一个转变。
那它会影响
就是整个这个太空站一样。
那次为什么会有这个转变。
这个也很有意思
它其实把这个产业从一个国家主导。
变成了一个企业主导的状况。
我觉得很简单
因为NASA已经被边缘化了。
对你再不做出一点事情来。
就是过去的这个30年躺着。
OK总会有一天
OK你需要交代
那
它需要引入粘语
对不对
这也不可能
就是说永远的将这个系统加下去。
就是任何人能看到。
就是一个非常迟的事情。
对
所以航天业慢慢的会。
越来越汽车产业化吗？
我觉得SpaceX已经是。
证明了这一点
并且这个思维
那其他的产业
如果要能够跟得上SpaceX。
并且能够竞争的话。
OK
至少能够做到这一点。
被造一个火箭
可能真的就像造一个车一样。
我觉得你造一个车子的概念。
我可以是说
怎么样把一个东西。
从一个工艺化
高度的机密化
做一个小量化
怎么样能够把它大量化。
稳定
OK的产出
那这个东西在SpaceX。
在飞行9号
跟在这个新建等等。
我可以已经是贯彻的。
那我觉得整个行业。
也是朝这个方向在走。
你怎么看待AI和航天的结合。
AI会怎么改变航天业吗？
我们刚才有讲到
我们就AI
我们最开始聊了一会。
对刚才你聊一会
就是AI怎么样
就是在航天怎么帮助AI。
OK
就是在太空建设
这些新的data center。
这些怎么样的可能性。
你是觉得航天帮助AI。
我认为这是一点
OK
就是以前是SpaceX。
跟XAI结合
接下来想要做的事情。
我也就是说
在这个新的空间里面。
OK
快速建设这个算力。
那这个是SpaceX。
要做的事情
在SpaceX可以做到事情。
那我不认为说
这个东西是一个很简单的一个题材。
即使对SpaceX。
OK
那你说做幻众话
来做AI
OK
做起来怎么样能够帮助航空航天。
现在不管是SpaceX。
要做的事情
在晋级
在这个data center。
或者说
你说跟人要去火星。
其实在很大的一块。
还是有很多的这个材料科学。
这一块
OK
还是需要不管是AI的。
是辅助的开发
或者是模拟
OK 价值上完成。
我觉得很多人讲
SpaceX的时候不会讲到。
就其实那SpaceX。
能够这么快的成长。
SpaceX
你可以简单来讲
它可能是一个最早的一个AI公司。
为什么？
OK
就SpaceX之所以能够这么快。
当然
SpaceX很努力。
SpaceX的人很聪明。
但是呢？
有一大部分是因为。
NASA
有非常非常多
在过去几十年
我可以说累积下来的数据。
给了SpaceX。
所以它的起点比任何人都够高。
那SpaceX也以一个。
现代就是
21世纪的公司的方式。
去开发的火箭
OK 运用了大量的模拟。
运用了大量
这些反正在这个模拟。
就在软体方面的资源。
能够快速的
OK 能够理解
在一个系统
他们需要把所有资源。
所focus在一个方向。
那自己也保留一下。
一个一个小型的出状公司。
如何以非常少的资源。
OK 能够做到
非常非常大效率
就是大公司
可能花几十年做的事情。
能不能以你管理过的。
分银酒号为例
能不能讲讲
AI在其中参与了哪些环节。
在我们这一方面
AI会参与的比较少。
AI比较主要多的是。
在这个产品的开发。
跟这个模拟方面
OK 在SpaceX所建造的。
他们自己内部
对这个世界的模型。
运火箭模型
但是在我们所谓的。
接下来模型以后
设计出来的东西
流程 生产 供应链。
这一块
SpaceX用的比较少。
在我那个时候
但现在非常明显
你那个环节
你说的是上游吗？
AI可能渗透的是。
更偏中下游的部分。
中下游当然有AI。
一个很大的展现空间。
不管是在空管
不管是在应用方面。
但在上游
你怎么样运用最新的开发工具。
最新的模拟
能够在更快速 更有效率。
能够来继续这些
最重要的火箭的设施。
这东西我相信
SpaceX在跟XAI结合以后。
或许会是更加麻吧？
你怎么看马斯克
要在太空建设AI数据中心。
这个缝大的机会
这是一个的确
太空提供了一个SpaceX。
跟数据中心
有一个可以成立的东西。
像我刚刚说的
在美国建设数据中心的。
两个难点
空间并且这个执照。
然后还有无尽的能源。
这一块太空
能够快速地解决
可以SpaceX可以快速地解决。
我觉得是一个
不是一个疯狂的一个说法。
但是也不是一个简单的路。
它是不是首先需要把。
算力发射到太空上。
是一个全新的一个。
你可以想想
除了Sullin以外。
另外的一个卫星的群吧？
Consolation。
这是可能的还是不可能的。
从一个工程的角度上是可能的。
但是是一个难的工作。
即使对SpaceX而言。
都是一个难的工作。
还是有一些在上面需要克服的。
能够长期并且能够量化的问题。
我说的不是说
这个东西能不能做到。
我主要说
这个东西做到了
有没有办法是跟地面上的数据中心。
是能够竞争的
或者超越的
因为如果没有做到这一点。
就没有意义
所有的标杆是做后者。
不是说能够做
做到当然很简单
谁都可以做到
SpaceX当然可以做到。
很多公司也可以做到。
但是能不能做到后者。
我认为SpaceX就具备这个条件。
但是不是一个简单的路。
而且还需要发射成本。
发射成本我觉得是一个。
相对比较简单的一个问题。
除了发射成本还有很多。
其他需要解决
把这个东西
像它整个的效能化。
能够比地面上的数据中心。
还要更算得过招
对方面的问题
你看Sam Altman最近就说。
马斯克的太空算力非常可笑。
我觉得他眼红
他自己反正我觉得OpenAI。
我不在这边说太多。
这种trash talking的话。
不要说新的机会
但是我们持续
在SpaceX就知道。
整个太空的接下来。
就是整个发展
让我们跟很多
可能机性不太一样。
我们不把太空当成。
是一个独立的一个投资的表爱。
就在我们而言
其实在太空或在地球上。
其实它是一个议题的。
有一些东西
适合在太空或者太空加上。
地球上的整个设置。
能够加持
我们是这样整体
然后来看整个系统式。
我们相信
太空特有的环境
不管是你刚刚说的。
我们刚刚说的
数据传输的速度
或者是一个非常特殊的低引力。
太空特有环境
能够做出很多地球上。
跟做不出来的事情。
或者需要发费
大费成本所需要的事情。
那我认为在太空
会更有效率
所以在
接下来的时代
我觉得可能
就是像很多人讲AI一样。
AI不会取代任何的人。
可是懂AI的人
都可以觉得比你都更有优势。
那我觉得接下来
通常这个话
就一样apply在太空。
这个领域里面
谁能够集合天上天下。
然后成为一个
真的更有效率
终止的一个系统
这是我们现在在
关注的一些公司
比如说什么样的系统。
比如说像我们现在看的。
在太空特有的环境里面。
在天生的
我们现在在讲
这个晶圆跟晶片
是一个
大家现在都在
紧急在制作
一个很重要的目标。
对
大家就要做一个晶圆场。
需要花费就几十亿美金。
OK 非常多
有了时间
OK 能够见照
但是如果大家如果去细想。
你用这么多的钱
所制造的环境
是什么？
其实很多时候你会想。
这东西不就跟太空。
现在天生的环境就很类似吗？
你简直是花非常大笔的资源。
在地球上
想要做一个太空
模拟一个太空
做一个太空的环境。
那为什么不在太空做这件事情。
那以前可能没有这一个选择。
但是现在我们即将就是在这个时代。
这是一个选择之一。
因为SpaceX打开了这个时代。
SpaceX能成为一个多大规模的企业在你心里。
回归到马斯克的话。
这回归到SpaceX自己。
SpaceX以前成长的规模。
对不对
它对标的是波音这些大怪兽。
它没有这些大公司的包袱。
它给这些弹性
那如今SpaceX今天有到两万人。
覆盖了所有你可以想象的。
不管是卫星发射
耗耗等等
给这样的这些事业权。
对所以SpaceX接下来的是。
你要如何能够维持SpaceX。
这是一个很重要的一个核心。
那如果SpaceX能够持续这样的保持。
就之前的这种速度。
跟临敏都的话
那像我刚刚说的
SpaceX的这个上线。
我觉得太空
第一轨只是第一站。
卫星只是第一站
月球只是第一站
整个那个的环境比地球大好。
太多太多的环境
在于一家公司的底下。
我觉得你可以想象这个势址是多少。
我觉得时间吧？
但是我近期
为什么到目前为止。
我都没有
出售我的股票
因为我认为SpaceX至少是一个万一。
至少
是一个万一级的公司。
在地球上面的这个。
就是我的应用
至少
至少 说了好多遍至少。
然后还有呢？
我觉得SpaceX可能做的两件事情吧？
第一
就是当然它打开了太空。
给所有
这些企业继续是开发。
把这些降低成本
然后提高这些生育率。
另外一个SpaceX做到的事情。
因为SpaceX跟特斯拉。
在美国这边
创造了一批
跟马斯克一起
懂得怎么样在美国这边做。
高深硬件的一批的。
年轻创业者
这一批
大家都认为在美国生产。
做硬件基本上是不可能的事情。
感觉中国更有
供应的优势
这绝对是的
绝对是
美国在新的领域底下。
如果真的要竞争
当然不能够直接把。
中国的厂
直接搬来美国
再重新再做一遍
这些创业者
跟了马斯克
不管在特斯拉
不管在SpaceX。
懂得
从0到1
怎么在美国这边
做出全世界最先进的硬件。
这批创业者
像我刚刚说的
排20几岁
30几岁 非常年轻。
头脑有资源
所以这批创业者
接下来
所开发的
接下来的第二个项目。
就是我们现在
所谓的Grand。
这些SpaceX Mafia。
也是我们非常
就是基金非常关注的一些项目。
那这些不管事实上。
你说不一定是在太空。
可能是一个超超音速飞机。
可能是一个mini核能。
可能是一个新的晶片。
产业等等
但是他们有一个共同点。
就是美国的投资
还是美国关注过去20年。
都是在软件的产业。
不管是新的模型
新的app
新的互联网
美国正在有一批
除了软件以外
可以知道怎么做一些智能硬件。
做下一代整个工业化的一些。
创业者现在正在开始。
他们跟马斯克的关系是什么？
他们一定跟马斯克。
马斯克是有一些共识关系的吗？
有一些一定有
对那有一些当然
公司这么大
可能每一个人都跟马斯克有关系。
在美国做高声硬件的。
有什么弄好呢？
怎么在美国能做高声硬件呢？
首先要懂得美国
懂得美国
当然就中国人讲那句话。
天使地利人和
我觉得在美国人和。
你要熟悉美国的独特的环境。
美国也不是适合做硬件。
或者不适合做硬件。
美国有50个州
50个州你可以相对。
甚至有50个法律。
也有一些不同的州。
有不同的强项
对熟悉怎么样
熟悉这个土地
熟悉这个环境
并且能够跟这个地方。
然后融合的人
然后同时
我觉得呢？
又有世界观
能够知道怎么样
这个全世界有了什么？
能够结合这里的优势。
我觉得这是我们在找的充业者。
这里的优势是什么？
是资金更充沛
这是之一
对那当然在开发
在迭代
那在算力等等
我觉得美国这方面都有优势。
那你可以换句话说。
其实美国也不是说在。
硬件上面没有优势。
我觉得美国有一批。
非常非常厉害的硬件的开发者。
因为美国天然的环境。
就让他们从小
反正动手的能力
非常非常的强
但是呢？
美国呢？
我们现在加州
可能会觉得说
这个生产可能不太可能。
可是美国还没有
非常的大的
容易到中西部
或者你到其他地方。
其实还是有很多很适合。
能够做硬件的地方。
你这么说
我突然想到
为什么在新的原车。
和在航天
似乎都是
都是美国
都是靠马斯克这笔独了。
是吗？
中国好像不是
中国就很准
我觉得现在是
因为现在是风头上面。
可是我觉得现在
接下来这些
SpaceX Mafia。
从马斯克体系里面出来。
各式各样的发展
不管是在能源界
不管是在新的制造。
不管是在车界
航天界等等
我觉得接下来
会有更多的
新闻的方法
你觉得包括中国的。
工程教育系统
包括它晚辈的产业链。
中国的航天在Dragon SpaceX上。
它的优势和劣势是什么？
我觉得我们蛮难平与。
这个东西
因为我不太知道
中国的情况
但是中国知道
自己的优势
中国在生产
在迭代上面
绝对是能够拯过全球。
如果是朝这个优势走。
我认为应该就是对的方向。
对不对
我认为这是一个
两个独立的一个土壤。
然后会培养出
一批非常尖端的
这些创业者
就像现在的产业鸯。
然后有很大的公司。
对美国有很大的公司。
我认为是一样的
但这东西没有什么？
我认为这可能是
大家最大的误解
这个可能是一个
大家会认为这是一个。
中国或者美国
谁比较厉害
谁跑得比较前
谁比较有点像这种。
就是你知道
你我这样的一个观测。
但是大家我觉得
没有意识到的是
太空的空间跟潜力。
可是需要双方
大家一起要努力
当然是太空有一个最。
我认为最ironic的一个地方。
中国的太空空间是什么？
美国的太空空间是什么？
没有所谓这个空间。
所有的东西都是环绕的全球。
所以太空是唯一一个。
全球必须一起共事。
一起所做
一起共同发展的地方。
你管理过太空站
在太空站上
什么东西是特别影响。
用户体验的
我们其实不好意思。
我们刚刚投了一个。
太空站公司
这是你只要在
太空站这个领域里面。
全世界有十几家公司。
正在做这个项目
然后我们投了
其中一个项目
可能是最新的一个项目。
那为什么我们投了这个项目。
有两点
第一
它有非常非常多的SpaceX的人。
在这个里面
所以它里面的DNA。
跟SpaceX密切的关系。
非常非常的近
第二
也就是在这个前提之下。
他们要做出一个
全世界前所谓
有一个新的一个太空站。
也就是我们说过
在太空这个环境里面。
一个最特色的
就是一个无重力状态。
或者一个少重力状态。
东西都是飘的
OK
那刚刚讲到
那在生活里面
OK
在这个太空里面上厕所。
可以是一个非常难的一个问题。
还有很多事情
是一个很难的问题。
OK
那这个大家可以去Google。
可以去想象中
这为什么难
那这家公司要做什么呢？
这家公司要做
全世界第一个
有一个可控地心引力的太空站。
Mixers
不是有地心引力
或者没有地心引力。
是一个可控地心引力。
也就是说
我们人类将迈入到。
一个新的一个世界。
就前所未有
在地上没有的一个世界。
就是在一个空间里面。
我们除了能够控制它的温度。
能够控制它的压力。
我们还可以控制它的地心引力。
这是人类前所未有。
完全没有的一个第三维度。
那我们即将迈入的一个世界。
当然他们对外讲
就是这个地心引力有什么好处呢？
我们可以有一个世界的。
第一个冲水马桶
在太空里面
所以之前这个问题。
是怎么解决的
哇
你想想这个吸尘器。
或者这个无重力
这个东西
你可以想象
这东西漂浮在里面。
OK
你要怎么去用这个东西。
那并且是怎么使用这个东西。
我觉得大家可以上YouTube。
应该有一些非常
这怎么说
Graphic的这个显示。
我怎么会使用这个东西。
OK
这个是个科研问题。
还是一个工程问题。
就是可控地心引力。
是一个工程问题
科学
这是一个很明显的。
一个很简单的物理问题。
它已经实现了吗？
它不是实现
它是一个很简单的数学。
完全是可以证实出来的事情。
之前总没有人做
哇
因为之前
为什么很多
很多事没有人做
为什么之前没有人做新建。
为什么没有之前没有人做。
会收火箭
很多人都会说
创业要聚焦
要专注
你看马斯克同时
能做这么多的事情。
SpaceApps。
Tesla
Apps AI
等等等等
它的时间是怎么分配的。
它会平均分配
给这些公司吗？
我不知道SpaceApps。
如果马斯克现在
会怎么分配
但我照
马斯克的态度
它一直认为说
它的时间只配
把自己放在
公司最困难的
那个问题上面
可以觉得
它是所有的公司
最困难
决绝不了
希望大家同心协力。
这个时候
马斯克会出现
这是我们跟马斯克。
一个非常明显的体验。
也认马斯克
不会在这边
跟你一起庆功
哇
我们今天庆祝了
这边300
背了300次
回收
了不起
但是你在
这个机械
坏掉了
并且这个机械
阻止所有火箭
就是开发生产
前进的时候
你会发现马斯克
一定在那边
跟你一起
解决这个问题
如果只用一句话
评价
它是一个什么样的人。
它是我到现在
目前为止
我认为是最厉害的领寿吧？
也是一个
我们对创业者
衡量的一个标杆
那也是我自己
成长的一个标杆
我觉得加入SwickSize。
好像是你前面的
去了人生经历里面。
最疯狂的一个决定。
当下是
当下决的是
对
它现在回头看
它是一个很
也是蛮疯狂的经历。
其实也蛮好运的经历。
我觉得很多的
创业公司
跟我们经历过
类似的故事
但是最终
没有我们的成果
那我觉得运气
绝对是一部分
我们感恩
我最后会
开始进入一些
收尾的问题
我们每一位嘉宾都会。
给观众推荐
一本人生之书
它要真的
对你人生有不影响。
你会推荐的一本
好 我们现在讲太空。
那其实呢？
我很喜欢
《龟骨王铁侠》这一本书。
那写马斯克有两本书。
一本是《龟骨王铁侠》
另外一本是
它所谓它的字传
我认为那一本字传。
有《龟骨王铁侠》
可能十倍多的资源。
跟时间
可是我认为
它表现的必妙
《龟骨王铁侠》的好。
也对一个
可能现在的创业者。
或者对这个领域里面。
新创
给感兴趣的人
我认为《龟骨王铁侠》
是一个值得去看的书。
你觉得为什么《马斯克》
驻岸有十倍的资源。
但是你觉得没有
《龟骨王铁侠》
表现的好
我个人认为
它们要把它的重点放在。
马斯克公司
应该最重要的精髓。
就是我们现在
今天讲的这个部分。
而是在
一些它自己
可能它自己
比较好奇的一些立场。
OK
这上面
对
不完全政治
还是跟这个X
后面的收购有关
我觉得不是马斯克。
最重要的部分
你觉得只有工作
能代表马斯克
我认为工作
你觉得代表马斯克。
因为马斯克
是一个非常极端
专注
并且永远focus一个人。
所以我认为
它的一个Typical Day。
会是什么样
那个时候在SpaceX。
马斯克
即使不要说一个Typical Day。
马斯克Typical Week。
一个礼拜怎么样
那个时候呢？
礼拜一早上
进SpaceX
以每隔二十分钟的时间。
开一个会
从早开到下午
下午的时候呢？
走个整个厂房
然后到隔壁的死
然后走一整个厂房。
到后面特斯拉的设计总部。
看特斯拉新的设计。
然后完了
到隔壁的这个
私人的飞机场
坐飞机
上北加去特斯拉
在特斯拉礼拜二礼拜三。
飞回LA
礼拜四
再进入SpaceX。
再一样重复
整天的这样的会议。
礼拜五
到周末
可能就见了
各国的元首
还在做什么？
特别的这些项目
不管是Boring Company。
还是Neuralink。
这就是它的一个一周。
早上一般几点看见它。
不定
按照
但是呢？
有一个蛮定的
马斯克的会议
是二十分钟一节
然后完完全全
没有间断
从早到晚
那所以呢？
我觉得做他的这个。
秘书
我的安排他会议的人。
也是一个
非常厉害的超人
还有几个秘书
我们在的时候有两个。
只有两个秘书
两个
但是都是非常非常厉害的秘书。
其中的一个
也是我们现在一个。
非常close的一个合作伙伴。
他的晚上最晚可以。
几点都看了他
你在SpaceX。
我没有可以去关注这个点。
但是从我的伙伴
特斯拉来讲
马斯克什么时候
最喜欢去特斯拉的。
产线上面
每日晚上十一点过后。
就是大夜班
到清晨这个时候
我是马斯克
对喜欢看产线的时候。
在那儿睡觉
也不是睡觉
就是在看第二班
在深夜的时候
就整个运转
然后看整个里面
有任何
不符合逻辑
或者是一个
就是愚蠢的一个流程。
然后把他在那个
当场去取掉
就是马斯克
蛮喜欢做的事情
在特斯拉
他的SpaceXS会干这种事吗？
我没有听说过
类似在晚上的时候。
做的事情
但是类似的事情
可以常常做
也就是说
譬如说我们在SpaceX。
有某一个部位
像我刚刚说的
延迟了
或者是有问题
那你肯定发现
马斯克肯定就待在那边。
可以直到这个问题解决。
直到这个问题解决。
马斯克是不是
硅谷这边
还蛮喜欢用华人的一个。
商业力的
为什么？
我觉得马斯克在特斯拉里面。
我可以透过上海
超级工厂
可能我觉得他
一定有他的感触
在SpaceX里面。
华人是非常非常少的。
因为SpaceX的性质不太一样。
属于航空航天
那也是反正监管
什么洛义洛书比较多。
所以SpaceX是。
基本上白人居多
是非常少数的华人。
更不要说华人搞管。
那还有一些快问快答。
一个全球范围内你喜欢的食物。
我超喜欢吃面食
所以我喜欢吃
台湾牛肉面
一个全球范围内你喜欢的地点。
我可能上辈子意大利人。
我喜欢意大利
一个少有人知道
但必须知道的知识点。
可以是一个冷知识。
我觉得你可以讲
一个火箭里面的知识点。
火箭知识点
我们讲一个太空的吧？
你猜
现在在这个低轨
有多少差不多10公分大小。
这样的随物在飘来飘去。
这应该很多
很多
3万多克
10公分大小
那也非常非常
超音速的飞机在进行。
所以其实在低轨
这是一个需要解决。
必须需要克服的问题。
基于你当下的认知。
你一个非常重要的关键的BAT。
是什么？
那就是我们现在在做的事情。
我们相信
太空才刚刚在起点。
大家很多人喜欢说。
它是一个万亿元的一个产业。
我认为不要这么直观。
看它这万亿还是怎么样。
但是它呢？
是会一个跟地球
跟接下来的发展一样大。
甚至更大的一个产业。
这是我们的BAT。
你会持有SpaceX的股票到什么时候。
当然这个不作为任何投资建议。
我
我不需要卖的话
我永远不会卖
永远不会卖
好的
我们的工作室叫做。
语言及世界工作室。
当你第一次听到这个名字的时候。
你在想什么？
这个世界最伟大的发明就是语言。
所以你们在探索
这个世界上最伟大的事情。
好了
今天的节目就是这样。
这里是商业访谈录。
是一档由语言及世界工作室出品的。
深度访谈节目
你可以到公众号
关注我们的工作室。
获取更多的信息
我们的公众号是
语言及世界
Language is World。
我们希望和你一起。
从这里探索新的世界。
也欢迎你在小宇宙的评论区。
与我们有更多的互动。
也欢迎在小宇宙的评论区。